So Leute, es hat doch noch hingehaut. Ich habe alles fertig für heute. Ich habe mir gedacht, machen wir doch heute noch einen kleinen Bastelor-Stream.
Ich muss gucken, dass ich alles da habe. Nicht, dass ich gleich noch suchen muss, während wir hier am Basteln sind.
Die Meta ist am Start.
Lötkram ist am Start.
Ja, müsste eigentlich. Raspberry Pi SD-Karte ist am Start.
Ja, müsste alles passen.
Ja, moin Leute. Also, bevor es richtig losgeht. Ich muss mal meine Hose richtig hochziehen.
Nicht, dass es hier noch
Yep
Reveal gibt im Stream. Das muss ja nicht sein.
Weil manchmal, guck mal, ich habe wieder die Kamera am Start.
Hallo, Chat.
Oh, ist das auf 60 FPS? 50 FPS, beste.
Beste.
50 FPS.
Ja, da sieht man übrigens den Kram schon.
Ja, da sieht man ja den ganzen Kram schon im Endeffekt. Ich meine, wir haben
mal gucken, ob hier der Sound aus ist. Nicht, dass mein Handy noch komisches Zeug aufnimmt, wenn man es dann doppelt hört.
Ja, das ist das hier oben. Also, das ist mein iPhone hier am Start. Und ich habe eine Sache festgestellt. Wisst ihr was, was mir ein bisschen
problematisch ist? Das ist das zum ersten Mal, dass ich mit dem neuen iPhone hier streamen soll.
Davor hatte ich ein
Ähm, was hatte ich denn davor? Ein iPhone
Zwölf?
Elf?
Oder so? Oder x, x, x, iPhone. Ich weiß es nicht. Zumindest, das ist jetzt ein neues hier oben. Das ist, glaube ich, ein 14er.
Und ich habe festgestellt, ich habe festgestellt, der hat ein paar Probleme mit Sachen scharf stellen. Guck mal, wenn man jetzt mal
wenn man jetzt mal diesen, diesen, ja, was ist denn das? SD-Karten-Reader nimmt.
USB-SD-Karten-Reader. Ja, guckt da. Und wenn ich das jetzt scharf machen will, passt mal auf, wenn ich das scharf machen will,
das wird überhaupt nicht richtig scharf. Schaut mal.
Der checkt, der checkt es nicht.
Das ging mit dem alten besser.
Vielleicht denkt er, das ist schon scharf genug, wenn man es hier hat, aber
also, ich weiß nicht. Das sackt ein bisschen. Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass, guckt euch das mal an.
Das schaltet, das schaltet einfach gar nicht mehr scharf.
Ja, also richtig, richtig, richtig hängen geblieben. Warum nicht? Das ist, das ging bei dem, das ging bei meinem alten,
minderwertigen iPhone, aber bei dem neuen funktioniert es nicht.
Schrott.
Ja, das könnte, das, wie gesagt, das, das könnte natürlich auch am,
an der Software liegen.
Weiß nicht, ob das, also das, das Ding verwende ich jetzt zum Streamen von der, von der Kamera. Aber da kann man ja nicht wirklich
irgendwas einstellen, großartig. Man kann hier den Fokus, man kann hier den Fokus zwar von Hand machen,
aber das, das bringt halt nix, weil, guck mal, jetzt habe ich so nah rangemacht wie möglich,
pass mal auf, so nah rangemacht wie möglich und so nah rangemacht wie möglich heißt im Endeffekt auch nur,
na okay, das ist schon ganz gut.
Na, ich glaube, dann erkennt man schon halbwegs was.
Muss man, muss man den Kram von Hand einstellen oder sowas auch. Also ich sollte echt mal,
falls ich,
falls ich vorhabe, so Zeug noch öfter zu streamen, so an. Samuel, danke schon für den Sub. Ich sollte echt mir mal eine ordentliche Kamera kaufen.
Gibt es eventuell eine zweite Makro-Kamera, auf die man umschalten kann? Ja, aber das ist auch nicht besser.
Pass mal auf, ich kann sagen
Telefoto,
Telefoto, so, und jetzt, jetzt zoomt das ran, aber es wird, es wird auch nicht wirklich, wirklich
besser. Es ist schon so nah dran, wie geht. Also das ist im Prinzip genau, genau das Gleiche von, von der,
normalerweise könnte man das jetzt näher ran halten, aber das kann die App, die, die, die checkt das einfach nicht, dass die jetzt hier,
die müsste jetzt hier quasi scharf stellen, was die aber irgendwie nicht, nicht, nicht hinbekommt. Ja, das ist ziemlich, ziemlicher Schrott.
Ich weiß nicht, was eine gute, was ist, was ist für solche, solche Streaming-Sachen eine gute Kamera? Das mit dem iPhone ist ja nur
super, super behelfsmäßig. Oh Leute, ich brauche ein bisschen andere Musik, was haben wir hier?
Ja, ein bisschen wupp, wupp, wupp.
Wupp, wupp, wupp ist auch okay. Ein Selfie. Naja,
ich glaube, ich glaube, ich brauche da irgendwas anderes.
Am besten auch noch was, was, wo man per App noch zoomen kann oder so, oder dazu, per App muss ja nicht sein.
Irgendwas, irgendwas Gescheites, was jetzt, was jetzt vielleicht nicht gleich 8000 Euro oder so kostet.
Weil, weil das ist Schrott. Das ist ungefähr, hier ist ungefähr ein Abstand, so von
so
30, 40 Zentimeter oder so.
Naja.
Meine Steckdosen sind auch da, ja.
Also, was haltet ihr davon, bevor wir anfangen zu basteln?
Ich, ich zeige euch, ich zeige euch mal die Dinger.
Deine Hände sind, ja, meine Hände sind nicht mehr ganz so pepo-fett jetzt.
Und, und, und, und ich bin älter, ja. Der Finger ist nicht mal so dick, guck.
Hier, also, passt mal auf.
Macht das mal weg. Also, das ist, das sind die billig, das sind die billig Steckdosen, die ich bestellt habe hier.
Vom besten Hersteller überhaupt.
Was auch immer die sich bei dem Namen gedacht haben.
So, und warum ich die gekauft habe, ist nicht, weil ich denke, dass sie super geil sind oder, oder gar nicht. Also,
das, das Gegenteil
ist der Fall.
Ich habe die auch nicht wegen dem, wegen dem Namen gekauft. Ich habe die gekauft, weil man die für, weil man neun, weil man vier Stück,
weil man vier Stück,
ja, weil man vier Stück bekommen hat für 9,99 Euro.
Lol, ich sollte vielleicht mal umschalten.
Weil man, weil man für, weil man vier Stück für 9,99 Euro gekriegt hat. Das ist halt extrem billig.
Vielleicht fackelt auch die Bude ab direkt, aber von der Idee her
haben die einen Schalter für ein und aus, haben eine ganz normale Stromstärke, haben aber auch ein USB
und sie haben, ich kann es euch mal zeigen, weil ich habe eine schon auseinander genommen, hoffentlich funktioniert das mit dem Fokus jetzt richtig.
Aber wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich funktioniert das nicht richtig.
Und sie haben hier, oh na ja, man erkennt es, man erkennt es nicht richtig. Sie haben da, guckt mal,
ne, man wird es nicht, man wird es nicht erkennen, glaube ich.
Shit, warum, warum ging das Fokusieren besser mit dem alten iPhone als mit dem neuen?
Also hier, guckt mal, an
dort, man, man sieht es nicht wirklich.
Das da, das ist aber auch wirklich mega klein, das Ding, ne.
Alter, der Fokus ist voll im Arsch, man. Also da, wo ich, da, wo ich drauf drücke, das sind ESP 82, 66, 82, 66.
Ja, das iPhone ist richtig am Hyper-G-Bane. Ich habe noch einen iPhone 11 hier, ob es mit dem besser ist.
Ich glaube, das liegt an dieser Kack-Software, dass es, dass es nicht besser funktioniert.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass die Software sagt, die Software kommt mit mehreren Kameras nicht klar. Naja,
sie hat immerhin ein Select-Menü dafür, keine Ahnung. Verstehe ich, verstehe ich auch nicht.
Was ist das?
Kamera vor OBS, das habe ich schon vor einer ganzen Weile mal ausprobiert, das hat nichts getaugt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ja, ja.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was es für Probleme hatte, aber das war Mist.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern, was das Problem war.
Vielleicht jetzt, ja.
Ja, das ist, das ist zu Bleeding Edge, das neue iPhone. Ja, ist schon ziemlich Mist. Aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, wir gucken uns mal an.
Wir gucken, okay, ihr könnt es euch aussuchen, Chat. Also,
entweder fangen wir gleich mit dem Ding an oder, wobei, gleich ist gut. Also, wir müssen, wir müssen auf jeden Fall noch eine Runde meinen Raspberry Pi flashen. Hier, da ist er.
Ist ja zurzeit teurer als irgendwelche Goldbachen, so ein Ding.
Und außerdem das gute, das gute Fleer Case, Leute. Fleer Case, beste.
Aber ich würde vorschlagen, bevor wir uns hier mit dem Flashen der Steckdosenleiste und so
starten, zeige ich euch mal die anderen Dinger, die ich noch beim Prime Day bestellt habe. Und zwar, wie gesagt, als erstes habe ich mal diesen Viererpack Steckdosen bestellt.
Und Milfra, der Name ist immer noch mega nice.
So, dann habe ich, Moment, ich muss mal gucken, wo ich es habe. Hier, oh, hoffentlich reicht mein Name nicht.
Hier, oh, hoffentlich reicht mein Kabel dafür.
MonkaS. Wenn es gleich irgendwas runterfällt, dann
hat es nicht gereicht.
So, dann habe ich einmal was bestellt. Das ist für euch vollkommen irrelevant.
Aber ich habe bisher nur ein billig Ikea Maßband gehabt.
Ich habe mir mal ein gescheites,
gescheites, wie heißt es offiziell?
Gescheites Bandmaß bestellt, ja.
Mess Champ.
Der Raspberry Pi gibt es wieder zu angenehmen Preisen. Okay, nice.
Angenehme Preise heißt nur noch 80 Euro.
So, dann hätten wir zu bieten als nächstes
einen, und da war ich ja die ganze Zeit schon scharf drauf,
einen Akara, erkennt man das, Tchadke?
Stell es mal so hin und guck mal, ob man das sieht, ja.
Einen Akara Presence Sensor FP2, das ist der neue.
Das ist irgendein Ultraschall oder so, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das genau funktioniert.
Irgend so ein LiDAR Ultraschall
Ding,
wo man relativ genau im Raum feststellen kann, wo die Leute sind.
Also das ist nicht einfach nur so ein Presence Detection Sensor, wie man das kennt.
So, man läuft durch einen Flur und dann
erkennt das so grob, dass irgendjemand durch den Flur gelaufen ist.
Nein, das kann wohl, und da habe ich Videos zugeguckt, das soll wirklich gut funktionieren,
das kann wohl sogar im Raum halbwegs orten, wo die Leute sind.
Also sprich, wenn jemand auf der Couch sitzt, vorm Fernseher, kannst du das damit
halbwegs gut erkennen.
Also sprich, da kannst du so Sachen abfackeln, wie die Leute sitzen vorm Fernseher und gucken Fernsehen und es muss mal einer aufs Klo und solche
Dinge.
Was kostet so ein Ding?
Das war
60 oder 60, 70 Euro. Das ist relativ teuer,
aber es ist extrem nice, da wollte ich schon lange mal einen haben.
70,54 Euro. Ja, da wollte ich schon lange einen haben.
Und jetzt habe ich mal einen gegönnt.
Meine Güte, wie schlecht das mit dem Fokus ist. Ich probiere das nächste Mal die iPhone App aus,
weil das Ding, das Ding versagt komplett. Ich mache mal kurz, ich mache mal kurz Fokus von Hand.
Lass mal, lass mal kurz ausprobieren, ob das besser funktioniert.
Wenn ich
Fokusstells von Hand mache, lass mal gucken kurz, weil das automatische Anpassen von Fokus geht überhaupt. Ja, okay, schon mal, schon mal
deutlich besser, würde ich sagen.
Aber noch näher rangeht nicht. Ja, jetzt, jetzt erkennt man es auch.
Ich lasse es jetzt mal von, ich steuere das jetzt mal kurz von Hand.
Also das Ding. So, dann
als nächstes
haben wir
als nächstes haben wir noch einen,
einen Zigbee Stick.
Hier, einen,
einen Sonoff Zigbee Stick, der allerdings nicht nur Zigbee kann, sondern
der kann auch, ich weiß nicht, ob es da drauf steht,
ja, bester, bester Fertigungsort
China, China Chinesen, Shenzhen.
Der kann auch Thread, der kann nicht nur Zigbee, der kann auch Thread. Also sprich, der ist
furchtbar, furchtbar modern. Dann,
das ist jetzt einfach nur just for fun zum Ausprobieren. Ich habe dann nichts dafür großartig geplant, das gab es aber günstig
und das wollten die in Massen loswerden bei Amazon, weil den Scheiß anscheinend sonst keiner kauft, noch ein Thermostat.
Das funktioniert angeblich nur,
I am smart, das werden wir noch sehen. Das funktioniert angeblich nur mit der Bosch Bridge, aber
ich habe gelesen,
I tried Epoch Cam, even before Elgato bought it, and
I can't really remember what the problem was, but I didn't like it.
I tried a few options, I tried
streaming via WebRTC from the browser and
the only thing that worked was the Camo Studio App.
So, also das Ding habe ich am Start. We are all sitting in one boat.
Also, das Ding habe ich gekauft, falls billig war und das funktioniert angeblich nur mit der Bosch,
mit der Bosch Smart Home Bridge. Allerdings habe ich gelesen, dass in Verbindung mit einem neuen USB
Zigbee Dongle
und
Zigbee to MQTT oder irgendwelche anderen neuen Sachen in Home Assistant, das in Kombination soll die Dinger
unterstützen. Das werden wir dann auch ausprobieren. Ob heute, weiß ich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich in einem der nächsten Streams.
Was heißt Steckdosenflaschen? Das heißt Steckdosenflaschen. Das ist genau das, was du dir da drunter vorstellst.
Machen wir heute. Guck, ich zeig dir das mal. Das hier,
das hier ist eine Steckdose. Vom besten Hersteller überhaupt Milfra.
Ja, das ist eine Steckdose, wie man sieht. Guck, da sind Zwischenstecker,
Wi-Fi, Wi-Fi, Zwischenstecker
und, naja,
das hat eine Firmware drauf.
Und die flashen wir mit Tasmota, wenn es funktioniert, wenn es funktioniert. Müssen wir mal gucken. Also,
diese Steckdosen haben nichts Tolles. Ich würde die übrigens auch, jetzt muss ich mal Autofokus wieder einmachen,
ich würde die auch nicht unbedingt empfehlen. Das sage ich euch gleich, auch wenn die gar nicht so mies wirken, weil,
keine Ahnung, ob die taugen, ja. Ich habe die wahnsinnig billig gekriegt. Die haben so ein China CE Zeichen drauf.
China Export.
Das sagt ja alleine noch nichts.
Also, die machen, die machen eigentlich einen ganz,
ganz guten Eindruck.
Aber, wie gesagt, ich bin, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich, ob ich die wirklich empfehlen würde.
Warum ich die gekauft habe, ist, weil die billig waren. Die waren wirklich extrem billig. Da gab es vier Stück für neun Euro dafür.
Das ist mega billig.
Normalerweise kostet sie
37 Euro. Aktuell kostet die auch wieder 37 Euro. Aber für neun Euro, für vier Stück, da, da konnte ich nicht Nein sagen.
Und, was ich schon rausgekriegt habe, man kann es leider nicht zeigen, weil der Fokus nicht richtig funktioniert.
Obwohl ich ein Bild mit dem iPhone davon gemacht habe. Das hier, was, was du jetzt nur sehr unscharf siehst,
das hier, guck, das da,
das da, da, wo ich gerade hier drauf zeige, dieser Chip da, das da, das,
was auch immer, das da,
das ist ein ESP
866 und das ist der, der von Tasmota unterstützt wird. Das heißt, theoretisch können wir das Ganze flashen.
Einen weiteren Vorteil hat das Ganze noch,
und zwar
hier.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das erkennt. Sagt mir mal, ob ihr das erkennt, Leute, wenn ich da jetzt drauf zeige.
Man, Licht, Licht und so ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich drehe, ich drehe das mal so rum. Dann, dann müsstet ihr es auf jeden Fall erkennen. Und zwar
hier.
Dort, wo ich gerade hindeute, da oben. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das sieht.
Das sind Debug-Pin-Anschlüsse. Guck da.
Das sind, das sind Pins.
Können wir mal, wir probieren das nochmal aus. Wir machen nochmal Fokus, Fokus.
Jetzt sieht man es, gell?
Hier, hier.
Jetzt sieht man es. Das sind Debug-Pins.
Das sind Debug-Pins.
Da habe ich extrem Glück, dass es Debug-Pins hat, weil die Fotos, die ich von den Dingern im Internet gefunden habe, ist, also Pins,
Anschlussstellen. Die, die Fotos, die ich von dem Ding hier im Internet gefunden habe,
die haben eher darauf hingedeutet, dass die keine Debug-Anschlüsse haben, was natürlich für mich doof wäre.
Ist das Motor eine Custom-Firmware? Korrekt.
Das Motor ist eine Custom-Firmware.
Exzellent. Ich probiere mal kurz was, Leute.
Wirklich, wirklich besser aufgelöst ist es jetzt auch nicht. Aber man erkennt, man erkennt, wenn man hier ran zoomt.
Passt mal auf.
Ja, doch.
Guck mal.
Hier sind die Debug-Pins. Seht ihr es?
Erkennt ihr es? Hier sind die, hier sind die Debug-Pins. Die Anschlüsse da.
Ja.
Das hier.
Zoomerino. Der FP2 funkt ohne Internet so semi-gut. Okay.
Für was, für was braucht der Internet?
Serious Marks, dankeschön für den Sub. Ja, ich kaufe immer irgendwas Gescheites. Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, welcher das ist.
Welcher ist es denn? Das ist ein...
Wo steht denn das?
Sonov ZigBee.
ZigBee Dongle Plus und dahinter ist, da drüber ist jetzt das,
der Aufkleber. Nice.
Dahinter müsste es, glaube ich, stehen.
Plus X.
Nee, hier steht einfach nur Plus X.
Ah, nee, geht noch weiter. Ich muss diesen komischen Aufkleber mal abmachen.
Plus X1. Nö, das sagt nix.
Ja, dann weiß ich nicht, was das für einer ist.
Müssen wir da mal reingucken. Es steht in der, in der, auf dem Aufkleber.
Ich hab da nix mit E und P und so gesehen.
X001GS07HT. Sonst sehe ich da nix drauf.
Keine Ahnung.
So, nichtsdestotrotz, bevor wir anfangen, ich mache mal kurz die Steckdosen weg hier, weil die anderen brauche ich nicht.
So, bevor wir loslegen,
wir müssen erst mal
MicroSD-Karte flashen.
Ja, mit dem Teil.
Krass, wie viel Ahnung du davon hast. Na, noch kann ja gar nix passieren. Ob ich die Dinger wirklich verwende, weiß ich noch gar nicht, ja.
Bei dem Flashen kann überhaupt gar nix passieren. Das geht alles mit 3,3 Volt. Da, da fackelt nix ab.
Wirklich abfackeln könntet ihr es erst, wenn du es danach wieder alles auseinander nimmst und wieder zusammen, also
wieder, wieder die, die, die, die zum
Flashen notwendigen Verbindungen abmachst, zusammenschraubst und dann
230 Volt da drüber lauft. Das, das kann, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich die dafür verwende.
Mir geht es erst mal darum, rauszukriegen, ob man die flashen kann oder nicht.
Flashchamp. Und ich würde sagen, wir machen mal die VM an und laden uns mal ein aktuelles
Raspian runter, der nicht mehr Raspian heißt, sondern, sondern Raspberry Pi OS.
Flashchamp, richtig.
Ups.
Schreibe ich
monetarisierbar im Satz groß oder klein?
Es ist ein monetarisierbarer Stream, klein.
Warum, kann ich dir nicht erklären, aber es wird klein geschrieben in dem Fall.
Die Grammatik-Hintergründe kenne ich nicht dazu, aber das, das, das, das klingt logisch, was Matt schreibt.
Rechtschreibt Champ am Start. Ist das JTag? Ne.
Das sieht aber ein bisschen so aus, ist es aber nicht.
Also, womit wir das Ganze flashen werden, ist folgendes, nämlich mit diesem, diesem Ding hier.
Machen wir den Sonoff-Stick weg, den brauchen wir jetzt nicht. Mit diesem Ding hier wird das Ganze geflasht. Ich versuche, den mal anzuziehen.
Auch wenn es nicht wirklich gut funktioniert. Das ist so ein FT, wie heißt das? FTDI?
FTDI Serial Flasher. Den, den schließt, den schließt man ein paar USB an. Dann hat man hier
plus 3,3 Volt, Ground, RX, TX.
Und hier vorne noch mal die gleichen Pins.
Und wenn ich Glück habe, passen diese Stecker hier genau hier rein, ohne dass ich die festlöten muss.
OTA-Flashen geht nicht.
Theoretisch schon, aber ich habe es nicht hingekriegt.
Wir können das gleich noch mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert. Vielleicht, ich habe es nur einmal ausprobiert. Manchmal muss man das drei, vier mal
ausprobieren, bis es dann letztendlich greift. Aber bei der Gelegenheit, ich wollte die Dinger eh aufmachen und reingucken, also insofern
3,3 Volt.
3,3 Volt sind es. Also man muss auch, Leute, da müsst ihr aufpassen, falls ihr sowas mal machen wollt. Und zwar, guckt mal,
man kann hier umschalten, zwischen,
keine Ahnung, ob man es gescheit erkennt, man kann mit diesem Jumper hier,
mit diesem Jumper kann man umschalten. Mein Gott, der Fokus in der App, ich muss echt eine andere App nehmen.
Hier kannst du umschalten auf, weiß nicht, wo es steht.
Hier, da oben.
Da oben steht es. Da kannst du umschalten. Der Jumper ist jetzt auf 3,3 Volt.
Du kannst entweder 5 Volt oder 3,3 Volt nehmen. Und wenn ihr 5 Volt nehmt, dann besteht die Chance, dass ihr einen 3,3 Volt Chip killt damit.
Und das wollen wir natürlich nicht.
Weil das kriegst du dann nicht raus, also theoretisch kriegst du es rausgelötet, aber willst du nicht. Das ist viel zu großer, viel zu großer Aufwand,
da dann den Chip abzulöten und wieder rein und so. Das ist bescheuert. Also besser, besser erst gar nicht kaputt machen.
Dann flashen wir doch mal jetzt einen Raspberry Pi, würde ich sagen. Oder ein aktuelles Raspbian.
Raspberry Pi OS Download.
Moment, hatten wir nicht so einen Raspberry Pi Downloader irgendwo, wo wir gar nichts mehr machen mussten? War das nicht easy as fuck?
Connect to virtual machine. Hatten wir nicht so einen Pi?
I-Imager? Oder wie das Ding hieß. Da musste man gar nichts mehr von Hand runter laden.
RpGitHub.
Ja.
Genau, Fyb, da nehmen wir doch das Ding wieder.
Das war doch nice, da müssen wir uns gar nicht selbst... Ich meine, es ist auch so kein Problem, das von Hand zu flashen.
Du lädst das ISO runter und die DS das auf den USB-Stick.
Yes.
Der Hunk wird, wird applied.
Okay, da ist er.
Der Hunk succeeded.
Das sind irgendwelche GitMagic Sachen. Haben sie irgendwas gepatcht?
Bin etwas spät drauf im dran, warum flasht der eine neue Firmware drauf?
Weil ich dann und nur dann keine China-Chinesen-App brauche
und es viel besser in meine Smart Home-Steuerung integrieren kann, weil Tasmota
einfach POG ist
als Firmware.
Tasmota sieht dann so aus. Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich euch exemplarisch zeigen kann.
Ich muss mal gucken, ich muss mir mal kurz eine IP raussuchen von
von einer Geschichte, die ich schon mit Tasmota laufen habe, dass ich euch das Web-Interface mal
zeigen kann. Das hier zum Beispiel.
Hier, ja.
Beispiel das Ding hier. So sieht das Web-Interface davon aus. Das ist, das ist eine Remote schaltbare
Wi-Fi-Steckdose, die ich habe. Ich mache sie jetzt nicht an,
weil ich nicht weiß genau, welche das ist. Ist schon ganz schön alt, das Tasmota hier drauf. Ich vermute, dass es die am 3D-Drucker ist.
Hinten bei mir im
im Serverraum.
Aber ich will jetzt trotzdem nicht anmachen, weil ich hier nicht beschriftet habe, was es für eine ist.
Weil vielleicht habe ich sie im DHCP beschriftet. Lasst uns doch mal gucken, welche, welche das ist.
IP DHCP. Also im Home Assistant habe ich es halt drinnen stehen, welche das ist. Da muss ich 60, 60, 108.
Ne, kein. Ah doch, doch. 3D-Drucker. 3D-Drucker ist das. Steht sogar drüber. 3D-Drucker-Steckdose. Ja.
So sieht das, so sieht das aus. Und dann kann ich hier auf andrücken und dann geht die halt an.
Aber noch viel besser ist, also gut, die kann beispielsweise auch noch messen, wie viel Leistung da gerade drüber gezogen wird.
Was aber noch viel besser ist, ich kann es damit easy in meine Heimautomatisierung
integrieren. Das ist das eigentliche Ding. Du brauchst keine China-App, du brauchst keine China-Chinesen-Software-Cloud.
Du kannst das alles lokal steuern, so wie du lustig bist.
Das heißt, alles was Tasmota-flashbar ist, wird Tasmota-geflasht bei mir.
Wenn es nicht schon gute Connection von Haus aus hat. Also die, die Shelly-Dinger und so zum Beispiel, die muss ich nicht Tasmota-flashen.
So schaut's aus.
Okay.
Pi-Imager.
Yes. Choose a OS. Also Raspberry Pi.
Machen wir mal 32-Bit. Ich bin mir nämlich nicht ganz sicher. Moment, gibt es nicht minimal?
Ich bin mir nämlich nicht ganz sicher,
ob alles mit
64-Bit auf dem Raspberry Pi schon funktioniert. Wahrscheinlich schon.
ESP-Tool und sowas gibt es doch bestimmt 64-Bit, oder? Das ist eh Python, das sollte kein Problem sein. Wir machen 64-Bit, komm.
Das ist jetzt so lang.
64-Bit Lite.
Interessant, das ist kleiner
als das.
Leute, was würdet ihr nehmen? Die 64-, die 64- oder die 32-Bit Raspberry Pi-Variante?
Für den Flash-Champ.
64. Was braucht man an Hardware-Tools, um Firmware auf Steckdosen zu flashen?
Na ja, gehen wir mal von dem Fall hier aus, dass du sowas wie ich am Start hast. Nämlich was mit
ESP-8266 basiert ist. Da brauchst du auf jeden Fall so einen Flasher hier, so einen Flasher.
Wobei es die in unterschiedlichen Ausführungen gibt.
Und du brauchst die Möglichkeit, Pins hier anzuschließen und dann kannst du flashen. Und ob das geht, werden wir jetzt gleich sehen.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es wieder irgendwelche Probleme.
64, okay. Weil ihr seid Chat-Gel. Okay, nice, gg.
Hi. Muss ich jetzt gleich Pseudo starten? Dass das, dass das funktioniert?
Nice.
Hat das, hat das den, hat das die SD-Karte nicht erkannt? Da ist es doch.
New USB-Device.
Sollte da jetzt nicht eigentlich sowas stehen wie erkannt als SDB oder sowas?
Ja.
Warum erkennt der den?
Warum erkennt er meine, meine Micro-SD-Karte nicht mehr?
Was ist das denn?
Hä?
Also mit dem Ding hatte ich ja noch wirklich nie Probleme bisher.
Wir pusten mal. Ihr wisst, Leute, pusten, bei so Steckkarten immer beste.
Immer der Pust-Champ.
Ne.
Wird nicht erkannt. Warum wird das nicht erkannt? Warum wird das nicht erkannt?
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob er es unter Windows erkennt? Ja.
Da ist ein Raspberry.
Habe ich Kernel-Update gemacht vorhin ohne zu rebooten? Das kann natürlich sein. Wir rebooten mal.
Wir rebooten mal. Das kann natürlich wirklich sein.
Prinzipiell erkennt das. Ja, rebooten wir mal.
Pass auf, jetzt boote der Raspberry Pi OS von dem USB-Stick. Nee, kann er nicht. Ist ja arm, was da drauf ist.
Reboot. Reboot hilft immer.
Du flashst gerade deine NodeMCU SP32 mit das Motor für den DHT-22, den ich von Amazon gekauft habe.
Nice, so muss das sein.
Mit dem habe ich allerdings nicht so gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Die sind relativ ungenau gewesen. Es gibt ja den DHT-22
und DHT-11 oder sowas.
Die waren also für meinen Geschmack ein bisschen ungenau. Die Dinger von Bosch sind viel nicer, aber halt auch eine ganze Ecke teurer.
Okay, schauen wir mal. Ja, das kann sein.
Da hat er es erkannt. Ja, man musste einfach mal eine Runde rebooten.
So, da machen wir das mal. 64-Bit.
Light.
Hier, 64G. Right.
Yes.
Schon funktioniert es.
Einfach reboot, wie immer.
Ja, Docker brauche ich jetzt nicht. Ich nehme das Originale. Da weiß ich auf jeden Fall, dass so Sachen wie Flash,
Flash mit ESP tun und alles über USB ordentlich funktioniert.
Welche Software benutzt du genau für deine Kamera?
Camo Studio.
Ja.
Camo Studio. Aber wie gesagt, das sackt mit dem Fokus von der Kamera.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das empfehlen kann.
SSH noch aktivieren.
Stimmt, wir brauchen jetzt ja neuerdings. Haha, cancel.
Man muss doch Passwörter vergeben und sowas jetzt. Aber der will nicht, dass ich cancel. Is overrated, outdated,
jebaited. Hier, enable SSH. Das muss man früher nicht machen. Warum, warum noch mal
musste das jetzt sein? Warum gab es kein Raspberry Pi mehr für lokal?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Super highly secure secret password.
Always.
Was?
Kannst du jetzt gleich nochmal machen. WLAN brauchen wir nicht. Okay, save.
Ich habe den Eindruck, der ist jetzt langsamer als vorher. Kann das sein?
Oh nein, Passworthash leaked.
Jetzt ist vorbei, Leute.
Seid ihr schon drin?
Lasst meinen Raspberry Pi ganz. Please, Chat.
Lasst uns bei der Gelegenheit doch gerade mal gucken, was aktuelle Raspberry Pis kosten.
Hey, das geht ja wieder halbwegs. Naja, es ist immer noch abfuckteuer.
Also es ist immer noch viel zu teuer, ja. Ich meine, es ist wieder
bestellbar
Minus 35 Prozent. Alle ihr Dummschwätzer. Normalerweise sollte das 4 Gigabyte Modell 30, 35 Euro kosten oder so. Da sind immer noch 100 Prozent mehr.
Ja.
Ja, 57. Okay, 57 sollte es kosten. Es ist immer noch deutlich teurer.
Aber
ich meine, immerhin
reden wir jetzt nicht davon, dass man das nur noch in komischen Sets für 250 Euro kaufen kann, sondern passt schon. Passt.
Was kostet das gerade bei Berry Base? Was haben die da am Start? Berry Base.
Naja, wir akzeptieren alles Raspberry Pi.
Früher musste man für SSH zu aktivieren mit Touch, SSH und Butschreiben. Ja, genauso wie die WLAN-Konfig.
Das stimmt.
Ja, gibt's wieder.
Gibt's wieder. Aber billig sind sie immer noch nicht.
It's been written. Continue.
Jetzt ist das Ding fertig jetzt. Yep. Yep. Yep, clock.
Dann schließen wir das Ding nochmal an.
An Raspberry Pi. Ich muss mal mein
mein Router
DHCP aufmachen.
IP DHCP Server
Leases.
Der Router muss geöffnet werden. Moment.
Wir müssen sehen, was das Ding für eine IP bekommt.
So.
Exzellent, exzellent. Schauen wir mal.
Okay.
Alles klar, Leute. Dann stöpsel ich es mal kurz an.
Gucken wir mal, ob das alles funktioniert.
Einmal Raspberry Pi am Start.
Einmal hier Chat-Gear-Netzwerkkabel.
Einmal
microSD-Karte rein. Da.
Ich weiß immer nicht. So rum?
So rum?
Ne? Das ist fast schon wie USB. Man macht es immer falsch. Jetzt ist es richtig. So, ist es drin.
Und den brauchen wir ja nicht wirklich. Den lasse ich jetzt mal hier in der Ecke stehen.
Und jetzt brauche ich noch das passende USB-Kabel, in der Hoffnung, ich habe ein halbwegs
gescheites USB-C-Kabel, was taugt.
Gucken wir mal, ob das hier tut. Okay.
Okay, er ist an. Blink. Blink-Champ.
Okay, er blinkt. Lasst uns mal kurz gucken auf den DHCP, wo denn da was reinkommt.
Raspberry Pi, Raspberry Pi.
ESP. Das müsste irgendwas im Internet sein.
Der Raspberry Pi beim initialen Boot braucht immer ein bisschen, weil der erst noch die microSD-Karte
resizen muss und sowas. Das dauert immer kurz. Also da kann man durchaus mal so 1-2 Minuten warten.
Wenn er nicht hochkommt, kann auch sein, dass das mit dem, dass das Stromkabel sackt. Da muss ich besser das Netzteil anschließen.
Bis jetzt sehe ich hier noch nichts.
Home Assistant? Ne, das ist es nicht. Aber er bootet noch. Ich sehe ihn wie verrückt blinken.
Blink-Champ. Aha, da ist er.
Da ist er.
1-2-1 als IP. Pi. Add. Ah, jetzt nervt nicht rum. Was ist das hier?
SSH. Keygen. Minus. R.
Yes.
1-2-3-5-6. Highly secure password. Da sind wir. Oh nein, IP leaked. MonkaS.
Shit. Chat, was mache ich jetzt? Jetzt vorbei.
It's over.
Hacker-Man ist schon am Start. China-Chinesen-Hacker, Russen-Hacker, Twitch-Chat. Alle schon auf dem Raspberry Pi drauf.
Man in the middle eingerichtet.
Und passt mal auf, Leute. Noch viel schlimmer. Noch viel schlimmer. Guckt mal hier.
Interne IP leaked von meiner VM. Raspberry Pi und interne IP leaked.
IP von der VM leaked. Shit.
Schock.
Leben vorbei jetzt.
Was will der?
Ach, es kam doch erst ein neues Debian raus.
Bookworm-Debian. Gibt es schon Raspberry Pi in Bookworm?
Gibt es wahrscheinlich noch nicht, oder?
Upgraded PiOS from...
Ich meine, nicht, dass es notwendig wäre.
Hier, Bookworm-Staging.
Warum wurde mir das denn hier nicht im Imager angeboten? Habe ich mich verguckt, oder sagt das einfach?
Oder ist das noch nicht auf Official Stable?
Weil das ist alles noch Bullseye.
Und das Auto ist sogar noch Buster.
Vielleicht lassen wir das jetzt auch mal auf Bullseye. Dann funktionieren die Sachen eventuell besser.
Mal gucken.
Wenn nicht, können wir immer noch upgraden.
Nee, das ist nicht das Bullseye, um was es geht.
Es geht nicht um diese Zielscheibe. Bullseye ist das Pferd aus Toy Story.
Das ist der Codename für Debian. Debian ist immer nach Toy Story Charaktern benannt.
Und Bookworm
ist das Viech.
Die hatten ja auch schon alle durch. Die hatten Woody durch, die hatten Jesse durch,
die hatten Buster durch. Buster ist, glaube ich, der Dinosaurier, oder? Nee, der Hund.
Ist der Hund?
Buster ist der Hund. Wie heißt denn der T-Rex aus Toy Story?
Rex? Ah, der heißt Rex. Ich glaube, Debian Rex gab es noch nicht.
Das gab es schon.
1996.
Da sieht man mal, gab es Buzz schon? Buzz war auch schon 1996 dran.
Was?
Moment, warum ist
Dezember und die andere kam raus im Juni?
Die haben jetzt ja fast alle Toy Story Charakter schon durch, oder?
Ja, genau. Da kommen die Namen bei Debian her. Sind alles Toy Story Characters.
Okay, also
let's go. Lasst mal überlegen. Was müssen wir denn jetzt überhaupt machen gescheit? Wir brauchen ESP-Tool. Gibt es
ESP-Tool? Wie kriegt man diesen Grämpel überhaupt auf...
Ach, guck mal. Sie haben das ja sogar dabei.
Lulweh.
Excellent, excellent.
ESP-Tool Tasmota
Tasmota Download. Jetzt brauchen wir erst noch eine
Binary and Binary Tasmota Release. Current Release.
So, wir brauchen ein Minimal Tasmota, weil ich nicht sicher bin, wie viel RAM das Ganze hat. Kann man...
Kann man über ESP-Tool die Memory Size
auslesen? Ich glaube nicht.
Size.
You can find the Flash Size by using the Flash ID Command.
Also ESP-Tool Flash ID.
Okay, good, good, nice.
Das werden wir dann mal machen. Erst mal auslesen, wie viel Speicherplatz die Steckdose überhaupt hat.
Ja, Chat, dann probieren wir doch mal unser Glück.
Ich glaube, du kannst die Firma theoretisch sogar dumpen mit ESP-Tool. Ja, kann sein.
So, also hier haben wir das Ding. Ich habe die Steckdose, wie ihr seht, schon komplett auseinandergebaut.
Kurz drüber switchen, dass ich selbst was sehe.
Ja, ich habe die Steckdose schon komplett auseinandergebaut. Also das ist das Teil, was später in die Steckdose kommt.
Und das ist hier das vordere. Und das hier ist, das ist im Prinzip das Board, was da drin ist.
Hat hier unten den USB-Anschluss, den man hoffentlich auch per Tasmota dann ordentlich schalten kann.
Und hier neben,
vermutlich ist das eigentliche Relay, das da, mit dem man dann die Steckdose an sich schaltet. Und der Rest sind so
so Dinger. Keine Ahnung. Ein Schalter hier unten, eine LED
und ein ESP-32 da. Und da müssen wir jetzt dran. Und ich hoffe, das funktioniert.
Also, wir schließen, wir schließen das Ganze mal an, in der Hoffnung, dass es funktioniert. Also,
ich erkenne das nur sehr schlecht. Von da unten erkennt man es besser.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ihr eine Möglichkeit habt, das auch zu erkennen.
Passt mal auf. Erkennt ihr die Beschriftung?
Halbwegs, oder?
Man erkennt halbwegs die Beschriftung.
Geht das?
Erkennt man? Ja, ne? Also, man hat, man hat...
Oh, shit. Jetzt habe ich es runtergeschmissen. Geil. Zerstörge. Destroyge.
Aber das hält das aus. So.
Also, wir haben 3,3 Volt. Links, links sind 3,3 Volt.
Danach kommt TX.
Dann kommt RX.
Dann kommt GND und dann kommt Reset.
Probieren wir mal. Also, GND, GND machen wir zuerst rein. Also, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass es sich erledigt hat
mit... Ich stecke, also ich habe hier, ich habe hier dafür... GND, GND-Kabel in schwarz.
3,3 Volt hier in rot.
Dann habe ich blau. Blau ist RX. Erinnert mich dran, dass ich RX auf TX stecke und nicht auf RX.
Das ist auch so ein Tipp, wenn es bei euch mal nicht funktioniert. Ihr müsst RX und TX
vertauschen, weil das ist ja Transmit-Receive und das heißt im Endeffekt,
dass die Transmit hier die Receive auf der anderen Seite ist und die Receive die Transmit umgedreht. Also, man muss TX auf RX und RX auf TX machen.
Nee, OTA-Flash hat nicht so richtig funktioniert.
So, dann probieren wir das jetzt mal aus. Also, wir stöpseln
den da auf GND. Ich hoffe, das funktioniert, Leute. Ich hoffe. Also, das kann durchaus sein, dass das,
dass ich das irgendwie festlöten muss, weil das, weil das keinen richtigen Kontakt hat, wenn ich es einfach nur reinstecke.
Das kann sein, aber wenn wir Glück haben, geht das.
So, also,
blau ist RX, grün ist TX.
Also, TX auf RX. Ihr seht gerade nichts, weil ich muss das wirklich nah ranhalten, sonst erkennt man hier nichts.
Eine Chance.
Dann haben wir TX auf
RX. Geht schon richtig rein. Hoffen wir mal, dass das hält.
Und dann
5 Volt. Okay, ich habe alles dran, alles angeschlossen.
Gucken wir mal.
Wir drehen das mal, wir drehen das mal so rum, weil hier ist eine LED. Und wenn wir Glück haben, leuchtet die LED gleich.
So, dann brauche ich mal ein passendes USB-Kabel.
Wo habe ich denn das USB-Kabel hin? Ich hatte doch eben ein USB-Kabel. Wo habe ich denn das hin?
Ach hier.
Nee, nee, nicht an den Raspberry Pi.
Also, jetzt machen wir hier den, das ist das Dumme. Ihr seht, guckt mal, das ist ein Mini-USB noch. So alt ist der Flasher.
Niemand hat mehr Mini-USB. Die haben alle Micro-USB oder USB-C.
Ihr müsst euch übrigens an der Stelle, auch wenn es eine Steckdose ist, noch überhaupt keine Gedanken machen beim draufgreifen hier.
Das ist ja nirgendswo angeschlossen. Das ist höchstens maximal 3,3 Volt. Das heißt, hier in der Mitte kriegt es das Ganze schon mal eh nicht ab und
da passiert ja nichts. Wenn man das irgendwie einsteckt oder so, sollte man auf die blöde Idee kommen, dass
nicht dran rumfummeln, aber mit 3,3 Volt und hier, was auch immer, das maximal 0,5 mA, irgendwie 500 mA oder so,
da passiert nichts. Aber passt mit so einem Scheiß auf. Nicht irgendwie zum Ausprobieren mit offen, dann anschließen oder so.
Ja, genau, genau. Und wenn man es einmal eingesteckt hat, auch wegen den Kondensatoren aufpassen. Ich bin kein Certified Elektriker,
deswegen habe ich bei sowas auch immer Schiss und mache es wirklich nur safe. Das heißt, wenn das angeschlossen ist oder
angeschlossen war, dann fummel ich auch nicht dran. Aber das war noch nie, noch nie irgendwie in der,
noch nie, stimmt nicht, die letzten 24 Stunden nicht in der Steckdose.
So, zack, anschließen und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt gibt es hier eigentlich nichts mehr großartig zu sehen. Ich stöpsel es trotzdem mal ein, ob man irgendwas sieht.
Ha, ha, Leute, es leuchtet. Seht ihr das?
Pog, das heißt, das heißt prinzipiell funktioniert es.
Seht ihr, habt ihr es gesehen? Die LED ist angegangen, oder? Hat man gesehen? Easy first try.
ESP Flash ID.
Prager, Prager, Prager.
Nee, shit.
Es kann auch sein, dass es schon längst gebootet ist.
Oh, fuck, wisst ihr was?
Ich glaube...
Oh, Bild umschalten. Okay, Moment.
Dev USB.
Was habe ich denn hier angeschlossen?
Minus, minus Port.
Ach, fuck, wie geht man das an?
Soll ich das vielleicht hier vorne machen?
Okay.
So, also das funktioniert noch nicht. Jetzt gibt es mehrere Möglichkeiten, woran das liegen kann.
Wir stöpseln jetzt das ganze erst noch mal ab. So, bam. Stöpseln wir nochmal an.
Also es gibt mehrere Dinge, woran das liegen kann. Nee, das Flashen passiert immer mit der gleichen Bautrate.
Also die standardmäßig, wenn du nix vorher konfigurierst für den Output und das Flashen.
So, also es gibt jetzt zwei Varianten. Entweder
ist mein RXTX nicht richtig dran.
Was
durchaus sein kann.
Habt ihr gesehen? Jetzt leuchtet noch nicht mal mehr. Guckt mal, Leute. Jetzt leuchtet nicht mal mehr die
die LED. Das habt ihr nicht gesehen, ja?
Okay, jetzt leuchtet es wieder. Wo ist das Problem jetzt? Heißt es?
Was hat er für Schmerzen jetzt?
Was will er?
Aktuell wäre ein Picture-in-Picture ganz gut. Passt mal auf, wir machen jetzt Six-Head-Time, ja.
Okay, Picture-in-Picture. Sehr gute Idee, Chat.
Kann man das nicht einfach copy-pasten?
Picture-in-Picture. Jetzt müssen wir natürlich ein bisschen ranzoomen hier oben.
Oh je, Moment.
Wie geht denn das?
Hä?
Und jetzt zoome ich hier noch ein bisschen ran.
Ja, jetzt ist
exquisite, oder?
Äh, fast. Jetzt ist extremely
excellent. So, so ist Pog, oder?
So ist enorm Pog.
Was hat das Ding jetzt gerade für Schmerzen?
Could not configure port?
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen? So, mal checken, ob das irgendeinen Wackelkontakt hat.
Nee, geht eigentlich.
Geht, geht eigentlich.
Was, was, was hat er für Schmerzen?
No such file or directory? What the?
Disconnected er sich die ganze Zeit?
Das ist ein Reboot?
Software outdated? Nee, nee.
Okay, also Leute, es gibt jetzt, es gibt jetzt mehrere Möglichkeiten, warum das nicht geht.
Das erste, warum es nicht geht, ist mein RX und TX-Kabel ist nicht richtig dran.
Da würde ich jetzt aber mal nicht von ausgehen, weil das Stromkabel funktioniert auch mit dem Reinstecken.
Das nächste Problem, was sein kann, ist, dass man hier an den ESP-Chip
das GPIO 0
muss auf Ground sein.
Und das wird abfuck, das jetzt zu machen, weil der GPIO, der ist, also der ist wirklich mega klein.
Ich muss mir erst mal das Pin-Layout raussuchen von dem ESP32.
ESP82-66, Pin-Out. Wo dann überhaupt GPIO 0 ist?
Hier, hier. Wo ist GPIO 0?
Chatge, wer sieht es zuerst? Wo ist GPIO 0? Da.
Okay, der zweite Pin von rechts.
Also von unten, unten rechts die Ecke der zweite Pin.
Das heißt, da muss ich jetzt erst mal checken, wo, welche Seite überhaupt.
Es ist ziemlich wackelig, Leute. Es geht an und aus und ich erkenne das überhaupt nicht. Sekunde.
Okay, ich habe es unten rechts, unten rechts.
Wir drücken, wir drücken mal kurz. Wir drücken mal ein bisschen und hoffen, dass es dann...
Oh, es ist rausgerutscht.
Alter, bleib mal hier liegen, Mann.
Also, man sieht es ja auch an der LED, dass der immer rebootet.
Der Button ist nicht zufällig an GPIO 0 angeschlossen?
Gute, gute Frage.
Vermutlich nicht, aber wir können es, wir können es mal ausprobieren.
Ich traue mich nicht, den Kram festzulöten. Das, das ist einfach zu, zu klein.
Guck, der resettet sich auch immer zwischendurch.
Ey, wir müssen...
Okay, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten. Das ist nicht richtig dran oder es ist nicht auf Ground.
Also, dann würde ich sagen, probieren wir mal. Oh, shit. Das ist wirklich klein. Das, das sehe ich überhaupt nicht richtig.
Was muss man machen, dass der Chip sich in den Schreibmodus schaltet?
GPIO 0 auf Ground muss man machen.
Eine Lupe, das ist tatsächlich eine ganz gute Idee. Ich habe, wartet mal, ich habe irgendwo eine Lupe.
Moment, Lupe, Lupe.
Lupe Champ.
Erstmal kurz anschließen, das ist nämlich sogar eine Lupe mit Licht.
Die ist dreckig, lag ganz schön lange in der Ecke. So, hier, Lupe Champ. Das ist eigentlich so was, was man da...
Pass mal auf, ich muss jetzt mal kurz umschalten, dass man was sieht. Pass mal auf, Lupe Champ.
Erkennt ihr da irgendwas drinnen?
Ah, man erkennt den ESP 32 so ganz gut. Guckt mal.
Ja, so und da unten links, hier, hier unten links ist ein Pin, den muss ich auf Ground kriegen.
Das wird, das wird was.
Bringt mir die Lupe aber nix.
Oh, shit, okay.
Wisst ihr was, das Beste dürfte wahrscheinlich sein.
Das Beste, das Beste dürfte sein, wenn man einfach... Okay, was ist hier Ground? Was ist hier dran Ground?
Das da?
Hier haben wir doch was mit dem Pin.
Ist das Ground?
Ground, ja.
Werden wir einfach...
Ich mach mal hier vorne noch Ground, ihr seht glaube ich nix, ne?
So, ich habe jetzt hier was und ich probiere jetzt einfach mal hier vorne...
Ah, das ist wieder ausgeschaltet. Einfach mal hier vorne was dran zu halten beim Rebooten.
Vielleicht, vielleicht bringt das ja was, vielleicht. Es kann aber auch sein, dass die Dinger keinen Kontakt haben.
Auch, auch alles mögliche. Ja, es ist halt, es ist halt ziemlich, ziemlich wild.
Ob das, ob das funktioniert.
Aber ich muss mal mein Picture in Picture irgendwie ordentlich einstellen.
Okay, da scheint nix zu wackeln, das geht ja reproduzierbar oben wieder an.
Ich halte da jetzt einfach mal was dran. Wo ist denn der Reset-Pin bei dem Ding?
Egal.
Oh, das, das wird, das wird lustig. Das ist super klein, alter. Das, das sehe ich, das sehe ich nicht.
Ey, Boomer-Auge, alter. Das, das sehe ich nicht. Keine Chance, ey.
Fucking... Wie kriege ich das denn da dran?
Das muss man auf der Suche beachten, dass... Du meinst, du hast motorflächbare Steckdosen?
Ja, du musst, du musst bestens genau in die Bewertung gucken.
Okay, Leute, ich muss mir das mal kurz, ich muss mir das, wir ziehen das mal kurz raus.
Ich muss mir das gerade mal etwas, etwas in Groß, in Größe angucken.
So, und, und noch mal kurz vergrößern. Ihr seht das jetzt, ihr seht das jetzt nicht, aber
ich muss mir das mal kurz angucken.
Das ist super winzig, alter.
Wie soll ich denn dort? Das ist extrem klein.
Okay, ich hab, ich hab eine Idee. Kann ich nicht, okay, wenn ich zwei Pins...
Hm, vielleicht, vielleicht kann ich das so hier dran halten, guckt mal.
Vielleicht kann ich... Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Dann, dann habe ich halt zwei Pins damit, mit auf Ground, aber das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Okay, ich halte das jetzt einfach so fest, Leute.
Ich halte das jetzt einfach mit einem Finger fest und jetzt muss ich irgendwie den USB-Stecker da reinkriegen. Oh, fuck it.
Okay, es leuchtet, es leuchtet mit einer spitzen Pinzette Brücken.
Gute Idee. Jetzt leuchtet es aber nicht mehr.
Aber jetzt leuchtet es wieder, okay.
Das ist, es wackelt. Das ist ja scheiße, man.
Das ist ja ein, ein Krampf, sondersgleichen.
Okay, kriege ich das, kriege ich, kriege ich es irgendwie ordentlich fest? Vielleicht, wenn ich es ein bisschen rumbiege?
Ich glaube, ich muss das unten festlöten, sonst,
sonst wird das nix.
Ist aber viel zu klein.
Das kriege ich mit meinen Boomer-Augen nicht hin.
Das habe ich auch noch rausgezogen. Es kann durchaus sein, dass das nicht richtig fest ist. Ich glaube, ich muss das festlöten.
Shit, wie kriege ich, wie kriege ich das gescheit festgelötet? Okay, lasst, lasst, lasst mal checken.
Ich meine, das kann ich immerhin, machen wir das hier mal ab.
Das kann ich immerhin ein bisschen rumbiegen,
sodass ich, sodass ich ein bisschen Platz habe.
Oh, fuck it.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Haha, wie soll das, wie soll ich das festgelötet kriegen, man?
Du kannst versuchen, die Kontakte mit Isotape zu fixieren. Ah, five at a time.
Ich meine, ich kann, ich kann das wirklich mal probieren. Vielleicht kriege ich, vielleicht kriege ich das hin.
Vielleicht, das Dumme ist, ich kriege es hier on stream nicht gescheit hin, weil ich halt nicht richtig gucken kann, hier unter der,
unter dem Smartphone.
Da wieder sowas, was nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Naja, das könnte ich mal probieren, ob ich's...
Das ist echt...
Okay, okay, Leute, wir probieren das einfach mal. Ich mache, ich mache das mal raus.
Das geht, das, guck mal, das eine geht schon gar nicht mehr raus, Lul.
So,
ich, ich versuch's mal festzulöten.
Ich meine, abmachen können wir es immer, so hier.
Probieren wir, wir probieren es mal.
Müsste, müsste eigentlich ganz brauchbar gehen, denke ich. Es ist halt, es ist halt sehr klein und mein Problem ist, ich komme, ich komme nicht richtig,
nicht richtig dran.
Beziehungsweise, weil ich kann ja hier nicht drüber gucken.
Tuya Convert, ne geht nicht, ist zu neu.
Lässt sich nicht mal Flash, Flash Champen.
Leider, sonst wäre ich, sonst wäre ich direkt, direkt am Start gewesen.
So, ich mache den Lötkolben dran. Ich habe irgendwo auch eine super kleine Lötspitze,
aber,
ah, guckt mal hier, was ich gefunden habe. Guckt mal, was ich gefunden habe. Moment, wir machen das mal ein bisschen in groß.
Ich werde die wahrscheinlich benutzen. Guckt mal, was ich gefunden habe.
Eine kleine,
ganz kleine Lötspitze.
Extremly nice. Dann werde ich das mal auslöten. Ich habe, ohne Mist, Leute, ich habe noch nie bei diesem Lötkolben,
wobei, ich sage jetzt mal noch nie, es kann sein, dass ich das irgendwann mal gemacht habe. Ich habe noch nie die Spitze ausgetauscht.
Ich glaube, wie geht denn das? So? Okay.
Und jetzt?
Und wie kriegt man die jetzt raus?
Kriegt man die da überhaupt raus? Oder nicht? Ich meine, die, die muss dann im Endeffekt da wieder drauf.
Aber,
muss man das vielleicht aufdrehen hier? Ah,
nee. Braucht man da vielleicht so ein zweites Ding?
Ja, ich habe auch noch so ein zweites Ding hier, guckt mal.
Das muss ich da gar nicht raus machen. Oh, Moment. Zum Glück habe ich meinen ganzen Lötkrempel alles in einer.
Guckt mal.
Ich habe noch so ein zweites Spitzending.
Und jetzt? Wie macht man das? So?
Ah, easy.
Easy. It's, it's off. Ich bin, ich bin zu dumm.
Wie geht das jetzt?
Moment. Das funktioniert? Hä?
Das ist zu kurz?
Aber, die habe ich mit dem Lötkolben zusammen gekauft. Das muss passen. Das ist doch genau das gleiche, man.
Jetzt.
Okay, man muss da einfach noch mal ordentlich dran ziehen, dann funktioniert es. Okay, so schnell wechseln kann ich nicht noch mal.
Naja, der ist jetzt.
Ich muss mal gucken, wo ich das hinstelle. Normalerweise habe ich halt auch nicht so viel Krempel hier rumstehen.
Ich will hier mal ein bisschen Platz machen. So.
Einschalten.
Lötstelz an Start.
Guck mal hier.
Exzellent. So, und jetzt habe ich ein großes Problem. Ich, ich sehe nichts.
Weil ich die Kamera drüber habe.
Da müssen wir mal schauen, wie ich das jetzt auf die Reihe kriege.
Achtung, vielleicht, vielleicht mache ich jetzt Haare, Haare leak. So, ich glaube, das erste Kabel habe ich dran. Hoffentlich, ja.
Och ja.
Okay, nice, nice, nice. Next, next.
So, jetzt haben wir hier VCC angelötet. Jetzt kommt hier TX. TX muss ich hier
Rx nehmen und Rx ist das blaue.
Ey, da ist kein Platz. Da bin ich doch gleich mit Rx an TX dran.
Mal kurz gucken, ob ich das ein bisschen wegkriege noch.
Okay.
Das wird, das wird wirklich eng. Das wird wirklich eng, hier was dran zu machen, ja.
Soll das funktionieren?
So, nochmal kurz gucken, ob ich das richtig, richtig drin habe. Das ist TX und das hier ist,
siehste, fast, fast verkehrt herum gemacht. Das blaue muss da rein. So, und jetzt muss ich das irgendwie dran kriegen,
ohne, dass ich die Dinger zusammen löte.
Das ist aber auch abfuck klein, man.
Bin nicht sicher, ob das jetzt hält. Ich würde, ich würde dazu tendieren, dass es nicht hält.
Okay.
So, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, fuck, das ist, mein Gott, ist das klein, alter.
Jetzt aber. So, jetzt, jetzt ist es dran. Und ich hoffe, ich habe den Krempel nicht zusammengelötet, ja.
Handreveal, OMG.
Wird Zeit für ein Mikroskop.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, das passt. So, jetzt haben wir Rx, TX.
Man könnte, man könnte, dass ich ein bisschen mehr Platz habe, aber nee, wir machen das.
So, Ground können wir dann ein bisschen abwinkeln, dass das vielleicht besser funktioniert.
Okay.
Es ist jetzt nicht richtig fest, aber ich glaube, es ist besser als nix.
So, und jetzt Ground. Man sieht halt gar nichts. Das ist so hängengeblieben, alter.
Jetzt hätte ich fast Ground und Reset zusammengelötet, ey. Es ist wirklich mini, es ist wirklich mini.
Wahrscheinlich bringt das noch nicht mal was. Also sowas kannst du damit nicht löten, das suckt einfach.
Okay, ich hoffe, das funktioniert jetzt.
Schauen wir mal. Ich bin mal, ich bin mal gespannt, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das jetzt, ob das jetzt tut.
Okay.
Oder wir haben es, oder wir haben es direkt, direkt gekillt.
Na, funktioniert ja sehr gut. Jetzt geht noch nicht mal mehr die LED an.
Porgy, achso.
Das Kabel ist auch gar nicht eingesteckt.
Ja, das sollte man vielleicht noch machen.
Beim besten Willen keine Ahnung mehr, wo ich die habe.
Lass mich mal kurz in meine Kiste gucken, ob ich da sowas finde.
Nee, keine Ahnung, wo ich das habe und ich bin mir jetzt im Nachhinein gar nicht sicher, ob ich das überhaupt,
ob ich das da überhaupt
bestellt habe.
Weil sonst hätte ich gedacht, das müsste eigentlich in der Lötkiste drin sein, ist es aber nicht.
Mal gucken, vielleicht habe ich das irgendwo. Na, mal schauen. Chat, habt ihr das Ganze beobachtet?
Ging das, ging das wieder an und aus hier oder ging das jetzt konstant?
War das konstant auf, leuchtete das konstant oder ging das ab und zu an und aus?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das war,
glaub, glaub das, glaub das leuchtet mehr oder weniger durchgehend. Das heißt, da haben wir zumindest keinen Wackelkontakt mehr.
Dann versuche ich jetzt nochmal RX und TX anzulöten.
Vielleicht, vielleicht von oben oder so jetzt.
Schauen wir mal.
Probier ich, probier ich das nochmal.
Also Crown ist auf jeden Fall nicht richtig dran.
Das macht aber anscheinend nix, das funktioniert auch so.
So, blau ist,
blau ist RX. Jetzt kriege ich die Dinger natürlich nicht mehr richtig rein,
weil das unten ein bisschen
Lötkram dran hat, das ist natürlich scheiße.
Und die Kabel sind auch so kurz.
Ah, sind ein bisschen entfernt. Okay, das vielleicht geht jetzt wieder rein.
Näh, geil!
GG, aber ich habe noch eine andere Idee.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das gerade gebogen wieder und ich kann das so irgendwie dran machen.
Geht, geht das hier noch rein, das RX-Kabel?
Okay, RX geht noch rein.
Ich schalte euch mal wieder um.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kriege ich das ja wirklich hin.
Leute, das ist so klein.
Ich sehe noch nicht mal die Spitze von meinem Lötkolben gescheit.
Geht das da, warum geht das nicht rein? Liegt das an dem Loch oder liegt das an dem Kabel?
Okay, es liegt an meinem Kabel.
Dann probiere ich jetzt einfach ein anderes Kabel da anzulöten und fertig.
Lulweh, geht auch egal.
Vielleicht habe ich Glück und ich komme von der Seite dran.
Das könnte tatsächlich funktionieren oder auch nicht. Ich hasse solche Fuddeldinger, da kriege ich immer richtig Aggressionen bei.
Dreh ich immer richtig durch.
Okay, weißt du was, ich probiere das noch mal von hier unten jetzt.
Scheiß drauf. Wir machen das ordentlich heiß von hinten, dass es rein fließt.
Jetzt habe ich natürlich das andere Kabel da so doof.
Aber gut, Scheißdreck, da kommst du echt nicht.
Wir machen das schön heiß.
So, jetzt haben wir es.
Jetzt haben wir es gut dran. Jetzt haben wir es gut dran.
Ich muss das einfach nur ordentlich heiß machen, dann klappt das auch.
So, jetzt probieren wir mal in der Zwischenzeit, ob das noch funktioniert.
Ich muss immer gucken, dass ich nichts irgendwie aus Versehen zusammen gelötet habe. Ich meine, ich sehe es zwar nicht.
Ich habe eine dritte Hand und eine Lupe, aber
das ist eine Lupe, die man eigentlich hier am Tisch festmacht und ich habe hier oben ein ganzes Kamerasetupzeug am Start. Das funktioniert leider nicht.
Ich kann mich auch nicht direkt drüber hängen. Man sieht das schon. Wenn ich wirklich so hier ran könnte, wenn hier so mein Kopf wäre,
dann würde das funktionieren.
Aber das funktioniert nicht wegen der Kamera hier oben drüber.
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob das noch alles angeht,
wenn ich es jetzt reinstecke.
Ja, willst du mich verarschen?
Du bist noch nicht mal angeschlossen gerade.
Oh, Ground hat einen Wackelkontakt. Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Warum hat Ground... Ja, ich kriege Anfälle.
Warum hat das jetzt einen Wackelkontakt? Eben war es doch noch gut dran. Aber gut, prinzipiell habe ich nichts zusammen gelötet. Alles gut.
Okay, dann noch mal rumdrehen. Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee. Hier, Leute, ich mache jetzt einfach hier noch noch ein Kabel.
Was brauche ich denn jetzt noch für eins? Ein grünes, ne? Das hier ist...
Das ist TX und das hier ist RX.
Noch ein grünes Kabel. Ich löte dann die zwei Dinger nachher zusammen und gut ist.
Jetzt machen wir erst noch mal Ground ordentlich dran,
was ja irgendwie nicht funktioniert hat.
Außer, dass ich ein bisschen abgefackelt habe das Kabel.
Was für eine Aktion für so eine Scheiß-Steckdose, Alter.
Aber wenn ich weiß, woran es liegt, ist es eigentlich ganz einfach. Dann weiß ich das nächste Mal auch, dass es ausreicht.
So, wir machen das Kabel jetzt richtig ordentlich heiß,
sodass das schön rein fließt
gleich unten in die...
Das ist halt das Ding, wenn du so mit super kleinen Lötspitzen hast, am Start bist,
dann hast du auch ein bisschen Probleme, das teilweise warm zu kriegen.
Shit, das funktioniert nicht. Das wird unten nicht warm genug. Das ist ja ein Megasack, Alter.
Ja, das ist ein Dreck, Mann.
Dann hol dir Ground vom USB-Port.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Chat?
Das ist eine gute Idee. Das ist wirklich...
Okay, das sollte, das sollte funktionieren. Das probieren wir aus, ob das geht. Das ist eine gute Idee. Chat, ich muss sagen, manchmal seid ihr
Five-Head. Ground ist ja tatsächlich das unproblematischste überhaupt. So, dann müssen wir mal kurz gucken, dass wir das wieder rauskriegen hier.
Ja, nice.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Five-Head, Chat. Five-Head.
Doomswap, danke schön für den Sub. Jetzt checken wir auch gleich, ob das funktioniert. Checken wir gleich, ob das funktioniert.
So.
Anschließen.
Zack, ist nicht, ist nicht an. Ja, okay. Ist ja auch klar. Ist ja auch noch kein Ground dran. So, USB.
Wo ist Ground, USB? Hier.
Doch, es funktioniert. Habt ihr... Ah, es geht. Ground auf USB.
Five-Head, HiIQ-Chat. Ja klar, das ist dann viel einfacher. Guckt mal, da kann ich einfach...
Da kann ich es einfach hier dran machen. Dann ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Sehr gute, sehr gute Idee. Five-Header-Chat.
Excellent, excellent.
Nur kurz gucken, wie ich das jetzt gescheit dran kriege, aber das sollte, das sollte funktionieren.
Das mache ich zum Schluss, Leute. Das mache ich zum Schluss. Dann habe ich jetzt noch ein bisschen, noch ein bisschen Platz hier.
Das mache ich zum Schluss. So, wir brauchen jetzt nämlich als Letztes noch
Rx.
Also hier den grünen
Tx.
Den grünen muss ich da noch dran kriegen.
Schauen. Also die zwei haben wir wirklich gut dran bekommen.
Schauen wir mal, dass wir, schauen wir mal, dass wir, dass wir Rx noch, oder Tx
noch gut dran bekommen. So.
Schauen wir mal,
wie wir das hinkriegen.
Ich mache mal USB, das USB-Kabel hier ab. Das nervt. Chat, habe ich meine Haare schon geleakt?
Hairleak? Nice.
Shit, das ist immer noch nicht richtig. Mann!
Kann das mal funktionieren? So klein.
Okay, jetzt.
Zwar nicht richtig, aber jetzt ist dran. Okay, nice. Und jetzt, jetzt noch Ground.
Nee, Moment. Bevor wir Ground machen, ich muss ja noch die zwei Dinger zusammen löten, weil ich ja so schlau war und das mit zwei extra
Kabeln gemacht habe.
Brauche ich nicht irgendeinen Clips oder so?
So geht, so geht auch. Soll mir auch recht sein, wenn das so in der Luft hängen bleibt.
Gucken, ob ich das warm genug kriege mit dieser Mini-Spitze.
Okay.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Es hält. So, also.
Wir haben Rx auf Tx und R, und
Tx auf
Rx. Und jetzt machen wir Ground an USB dran. Und dann sollten wir good to go sein.
Problem ist jetzt nur,
ich bräuchte eine Wäscheklammer oder irgendwas.
GPIO 0. Das stimmt, GPIO 0 fehlt. Das Problem ist, GPIO 0 kriege ich nicht dran gelötet. Das ist, das ist zu klar.
Also da habe ich ja schon Probleme.
Kriege ich das einfach so dran. Da ist ja ein bisschen Lötzinn.
Jetzt bräuchte ich eine ein bisschen größere, ein bisschen größere Spitze hier, um das warm zu kriegen.
Ja, jetzt wäre eine größere Spitze natürlich enorm praktisch.
Jetzt ist ordentlich dran.
Hängt auch nirgendswo. Okay, jetzt, Moment der Wahrheit.
Es ist alles dran. Es ist alles halbwegs fest. Ich drehe es mal so um, dass man die LED sieht.
Sind die Original-Firmen-Daten überhaupt signalisiert?
Was, was soll signalisiert bedeuten in dem Zusammenhang?
Was? Nee, nee, nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Es gibt, es gibt einen OTA, aber das geht nur für alte Firmware-Versionen.
Aha, es leuchtet.
Horgu!
Gut, das Auslesen geht immer noch nicht. Nee,
Tuja Flat, du meinst Tuja Convert.
So, jetzt muss ich GPIO irgendwie auf, GPIO 0 irgendwie auf Ground kriegen.
Aber der Krempel funktioniert jetzt wenigstens richtig.
Ich meine, das Ding resettet sich zwischendurch, aber okay.
Meinetwegen.
Okay, wie flasht man eine Tasmota?
Habe ich eine Tasmota schon runtergeladen, ein aktuelles Tasmota-Release?
Tasmota Binarys, Tasmota Light wollen wir haben, dass wir sicher sind, dass es auch drauf passt.
Ach so, ihr seht gar nichts, gell?
Wie geht? Nimm den Klebestreif.
Klebestreif, das Ding ist wirklich extrem klein.
Gebt man jetzt einfach die Firmware so hinten an, mein TAR-GZ.
TAR XFZV, TX auf RX und
es ist alles richtig angeschlossen.
Okay, da ist alles richtig angeschlossen.
Vielleicht, Leute, vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück und der Button,
vielleicht haben wir Glück und der Button ist wirklich auf Flash-Modus.
Hast du Lackdraht da? Ja, habe ich.
Habe ich.
Hey, das Problem ist, das ist so klein, guck mal.
Da kommst du nicht dran an den Pin.
Guck mal, siehst du, wie klein das ist?
Du musst theoretisch, guck mal, hier hast du sowas, hier unten müssen wir dran.
Das hier ist GPIO 0 und das ist so, also wer gedacht hat, das hier ist jetzt schon klein gewesen gerade, was wir gelötet haben.
Achso, ich muss eigentlich mal kurz umschalten.
Guck mal, hier muss ich es dran halten mit einem Lackdraht vielleicht.
Aber ich habe eine andere Idee noch. Ich habe noch eine andere Idee.
Und zwar, wir machen das jetzt noch mal raus.
So, jetzt halte ich den Knopf gedrückt, vielleicht bringt das nämlich was.
Der Knopf ist gedrückt.
Jetzt muss ich reverse.
Ach, fuck. Nee, hat es jetzt funktioniert?
Das hat funktioniert.
MAC-Adresse, guck mal, der kann die MAC-Adresse auslesen.
Da ist schon mal, da ist auf jeden Fall schon mal was dabei.
Haben die das disabled, dass man flashen kann?
Right. Wie flasht man denn jetzt?
ESP-Tool, Flash, Tasmota, ESP-Tool.
Da musste man, es musste man doch einfach hinten dran halten,
hinten dran schreiben, oder?
ESP-Tool.
Alter, was ist das für eine scheiß Anleitung, Alter?
Ja, it's not known flash size.
Nee, nee, das Ding ist nicht aus.
Der ist im Flash-Modus, guck mal, du kannst doch sogar
Detected Flash Size ist 1 MB, der ist im Flash-Modus gerade.
Button gedrückt halten, FS1.
Ja, das ist doch das, was ich machen will.
Right, Flash.
Tasmota light bin.
Oh, oh, Pulse Champ, Pulse Champ!
Es flasht, huge, Pogu.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Easy as fuck, easy, easy, easy as fuck, easy, easy, easy as fuck.
Das war, das war way too easy.
Die defeated haben wir ihn
so richtig rumgefurscht.
Ja, wie, wie würdest du das anders machen wollen jetzt?
Und jetzt die anderen drei?
Aber ich weiß jetzt, woran es liegt.
Es lag die ganze Zeit wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sehr daran,
dass sie einen schlechten, schlechten, schlechten Kontakt haben,
sondern Hard Reset via PIN.
Okay, ich mache mal kurz
Wi-Fi-Search auf.
Ob der jetzt in Tasmota startet?
Flash ID, Flash, Flash ID.
Ach, der konnte ja nicht resetten.
Ich muss den Eimer von Hand resetten jetzt.
Ich muss den Eimer von Hand resetten.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, zack.
So, WLAN.
Tasmota, da ist er.
Der kommt hoch, der startet, hat ein offenes WLAN, Pog, Extremely Hyper Pog.
So, jetzt habe ich ein anderes Problem.
Ich weiß mein WLAN Passwort aus dem Kopf gerade nicht.
Äh, ich, Moment, ich muss mal kurz,
muss mal nachgucken, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, ne.
Aber jetzt, jetzt kann ich hier auch nichts mehr abfragen.
Okay, okay, ich muss mal kurz hier auf meinem zweiten Desktop
meine VM starten für meine, für meine Access Points.
Und, Moment, was für eine Frage?
Und was ist jetzt für ein Modell?
Was meinst du?
Oh, shit, Leute.
Oh, shit, ich habe die, oh nein.
Ich habe die VM nicht mal auf meiner zweiten Kiste drauf.
Ich gucke mal ins Key Pass.
Ich habe ja noch ein Backup WLAN Passwort.
Also eins, was nicht gerätespezifisch ist.
Hier, WLAN.
Ja, okay, das, das müsste, das müsste damit auch gehen.
Das, das müsste, müsste auch gehen.
Ja, ja, das müsste, müsste, denke ich, auch gehen.
So, dann machen wir es mal an.
Warum ist die Playlist eigentlich weg?
So, ich mache es mal wieder an.
Okay, es ist wieder an.
Und jetzt gehen wir mal in WLAN Settings.
Tasmota.
Vielleicht muss ich auch mein, mein iPhone holen, dass das funktioniert.
Was für eine Tasmota Version habe ich denn geflasht?
13.
Okay, Chat, ich muss nur gucken, dass ich mich jetzt nicht vertippe.
Wi-Fi, select your Wi-Fi Network.
Okay, okay, reboote das jetzt.
Ich muss, ich muss in.
DHCP gucken, ob da jetzt was kommt.
60, okay, angeblich 60, 1.
Pingt das? Okay, ja, da sind wir.
Da sind wir, Leute.
Vorlage hast du?
Nee, noch nicht, aber da werden wir uns jetzt gleich eine holen.
Jetzt müssen wir erst mal eine richtige Tasmota-Version draufflashen.
Leute, mein Headset ist total verheadert.
Ich gebe, ich gebe dir Header, Alter.
Ich gebe dir Header.
Jetzt machen wir hier mal den Kram weg.
Kurz, kurz den Stecker raus machen.
Ja, okay.
Nice.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt vorher erst noch mal,
da muss ich euch, glaube ich, gerade mal wieder umschalten.
Ich weiß, ob ihr das sehen solltet.
NTP-Server setzen mit Tasmota.
NTP-Server 1, genau, NTP-Server 1.
Der muss nämlich eine interne NTP-IP kriegen.
Sonst kann er sich die Uhrzeit nicht holen.
Okay, nice, jetzt könnt ihr wieder zugucken.
Alles klar, da sind wir.
Okay, firmware upgrade.
Dann brauchen wir jetzt noch mal das neueste Tasmota,
weil Over-the-Air-Update wird nicht funktionieren.
Device will restart in a few seconds.
Funktioniert doch nicht.
Du kommst doch nicht ins Internet, Tasmota-Man.
Ja, da ist er auch wieder.
Du kommst doch nicht ins Internet.
Okay, firmware upgrade.
Das ist doch IoT-WLAN.
Das kommt doch nirgendswohin.
So, also, Tasmota-Bin, das ganz normale Tasmota brauchen wir hier.
Nicht GZ, kein ZigBee, kein Xen, so was.
Das Schöne ist, wir haben eins mit einem Megabyte Flash-Size.
Das ist gar nicht so übel.
Da könnte man theoretisch sogar ein größeres Tasmota inszenieren.
Aber wir brauchen kein größeres Tasmota,
weil da ist ja nix dran.
Okay, Download.
Nicht size-modified.
Tasmota-Bin, 21.23 Uhr hier.
Start-upgrade.
Moin, Anpe87.
Chat, jetzt mal ehrlich,
hättet ihr gedacht, dass das nach den anfänglichen Sachen funktioniert?
Also, ich war skeptisch, als es erst nicht funktioniert hat.
Also, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es einfach geht.
Not enough space? Willst du mich verarschen?
Das Ding hat ein MB Flash-Size.
Wollen die mich rollen, oder was?
Vielleicht soll ich das TGZ hochladen.
Das Minimal ist ja schon drauf.
Ich will vom Minimal auf die normale Firmware switchen.
Das ist doch schon Minimal.
Guck hier.
Ich hatte doch ...
Oder Moment, ist das nicht Minimal?
Doch, Tasmota Lite.
Ach, ich hab Lite installiert, nicht Minimal. Ist das ein Unterschied?
Ah, ich hab Lite installiert.
Ach so, ich Kacknub.
Ich wollte Minimal ...
Egal, hat auch funktioniert.
Ey, passt schon.
Ging auch so.
Tasmota.
Danke für die Subs, Leute.
Ich hab ganz vergessen, reinzugucken.
Ich schau mal, wer hat sich ...
Doomswap am Start, ResubscribedLeon auch wieder am Start.
DasJeroesMax auch und der Samuel.
Und Anpe, dich hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Dankeschön. PogSubscriptions, Leute.
Da sind wir.
Okay, jetzt brauch ich KS501.
Tasmota.
Ja.
Yuan Guo.
Ha, ha, ha.
Oder Leshp.
Alles der gleiche Schrott.
Ah, das ist die Ami-Variante.
Okay.
Hier, Template.
Yuan Guo KS501.
Yuan Guo.
Oder wie der Dota-Witch-Doktor sagen würde,
look at it go.
Yuan Guo.
Ähm, wie ging das jetzt noch mal?
Configuration.
Template.
Nee.
Äh, other.
Ja, other, other.
Ja, Template.
Activate.
Ähm, DeviceName.
Ähm.
Milfra.
Da weiß ich wenigstens. Milfra 1 ist es jetzt.
Okay.
Waren die Steckdosen von Prime da wirklich ESP?
Ja.
Okay, ich muss mal kurz hören, ob man das Relay hört.
Hört man das Relay schalten?
Moment.
Hört man.
Seht ihr es auch in der Vorschau?
Dass das Relay schaltet?
Also mit der LED zusammen?
Ja, das sieht man in der Vorschau.
Oh.
An?
Also ich höre es mit Kopfhörer auf nicht,
aber ich höre noch mal.
An?
Ja, man hört es klicken.
Man hört es klicken.
Mal gucken, ob der Knopf funktioniert, der Button.
An?
Oh, es hat sogar grün geleuchtet zwischendurch.
Wow.
Hyper.
Hyper advanced, Alter.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Grün hat es geleuchtet zwischendurch.
Moment, das ist eine Ampel.
Guck mal.
Das, das, ne.
Das leuchtet gelb, gelb-rot aus.
Rot, rot-grün-gelb.
What the f...
Okay, keine Ahnung, was die China-Chinesen da gebaut haben,
aber es funktioniert.
Aber ihr seht das ja so gar nicht.
Hier, so seht ihr das.
Guck mal.
Wenn ich einschalte, wenn ich einschalte.
Wenn ich einschalte, aus-rot-grün-gelb.
Und wenn ich ausschalte, gelb-rot-aus.
What?
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir können ablöten und wieder zusammenbauen.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, wie man die zusammenbaut, gescheit.
Ist USB schaltbar?
Stimmt.
Nee, USB schaltet direkt zusammen.
Normalerweise müsste man zwei Sachen haben.
USB ist nicht einzelschaltbar?
Das ist aber doof.
USB ist anscheinend immer an.
Oder USB schaltet mit der Main.
Ja gut, das Ding hat ja auch nur einen Relay.
Guck mal.
Also das kann das gar nicht getrennt voneinander schalten.
Und von dem Relay geht auch nix, nix an USB.
Also kannst du noch zeigen, wie du es jetzt verlötet hast?
Ja.
Ich guck gerade, ob es irgendwie sein könnte, dass der USB getrennt.
Ich mein, das sind ja nur 5 Volt.
Es könnte sein, dass es hier drüber geschaltet werden kann.
Na gut.
So.
Es ist jetzt eh aus.
Machen wir das hier mal ab.
Und das hier ab.
Ja, ich kann zeigen, wie ich es verlötet hab.
Und zwar.
So.
Erkennt man bloß nicht viel.
Moment, da muss ich die.
Das.
Ja.
Das wirst du jetzt halt nicht richtig erkennen.
Ganz links, ganz links ist 3,3 Volt.
RXTX.
Und Ground.
Und Ground hatte ich die ganze Zeit hier unten.
An dem 5 Volt Ground vom USB dran.
Also insofern.
Ja, jetzt kann ich den Kram ja wieder ablöten.
Ich mein, Flash Champ hat ja funktioniert.
Jetzt muss ich es ablöten und dann kann ich es wieder zusammenbauen.
Und dann können wir hoffen, dass es funktioniert.
Ob ich das dann wirklich benutzen werde, das sei mal dahingestellt.
Weil ich hab ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel Vertrauen in eine Steckdose,
die 9 Euro für 4 Stück kostet.
Und auch noch smart sein möchte.
Also ich weiß nicht, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen.
Aber normalerweise kosten sie auch 35 Euro.
Lul.
Also ich weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, ob ich das benutzen werde.
Aber mal zusammenbauen und anschließen können wir es ja mal.
Davon fackelt ja nicht die Bude ab.
Ah, ich kacke, jetzt hätte ich die.
Jetzt hätte ich nicht die kleine Spitze nehmen sollen,
sondern gleich die große Spitze.
Ah, jetzt hätte ich mich fast verbrannt.
So, exzellent.
Alles wieder ab.
MonkaS.
Monka Brandblase.
Ne, so schlimm ist es nicht.
So, alles ab.
AVM sind aber deckt und kein WLAN.
Das, hä?
Wie jetzt?
Ach so, die AVM Steckdosen, ja die sind deckt.
Das ist richtig.
Gut, jetzt können wir das Flash Zeug weg machen.
Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Schmeiß ich mal kurz hier in die Ecke.
So, dann lasst uns mal gerade den Kram noch zusammenbauen.
Strom vom Lötkolben aus.
Abmachen.
Zack.
Ups.
Mal aufräumen, sonst habe ich hier zu wenig Platz.
So, jetzt mal gucken, wie wir das wieder zusammengebaut kriegen, das Ding.
Okay, also im Prinzip ist es ja nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Ich muss das Ding da rein machen wieder.
Hier war der Knopf.
Guckt, sieht man auch, da war der Knopf.
So.
Kunst ist drin.
So, jetzt müssen wir den Knopf da dran machen, wie auch immer das genau funktioniert.
So rum vielleicht?
Tatsächlich, guckt mal.
Oh, geile Konstruktion hier, Knopf.
Knopf am Start.
Okay, jetzt muss ich das wieder festschrauben alles.
Zwei Schrauben haben, äh, Chatge?
Ich glaube, ich habe im Eifer des Gefechts zwei Schrauben verloren.
Ihr meint die hier?
Ja, das reicht aber nicht.
Das müssten vier Stück sein.
Guck.
Eins, zwei und dann noch drei, zwei andere.
Wo sind die hin?
Rechts im Bild?
Ihr meint die hier, ne?
Die sind es nicht.
Das sind zwei, wir brauchen vier insgesamt.
Das sind nur zwei, wir brauchen vier Stück.
Seht ihr noch irgendwo was?
Ich sehe keine mehr.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben die verloren.
Können wir die nicht zusammenbauen?
Eine habe ich gefunden.
Die ist tatsächlich runtergefallen.
Oh, shit.
Leute, die finde ich nie wieder, die andere Schraube.
Unter dem Raspberry Pi, gute Idee.
Nope.
Oh, die finde ich, ich gehe mal kurz.
Ich habe doch hier irgendwo meine Lampe.
Wo ist denn die?
Äh, die habe ich nicht.
Ähm, no Chat.
Lol, Leute, im Leben werde ich die hier nicht finden.
Das sind so ganz, ganz kleine Furzschrauben, Alter.
Ich meine, ich mache jetzt die drei, die ich habe, schon mal rein.
Was habe ich denn hier?
Ich habe hier so einen billigen Minischraubendreher.
Der war bei irgendeinem Kühler mal dabei.
So ein 1-Euro-Ding.
Aber ich glaube, der ist genau richtig von der Größe für diese Schrauben.
So, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie wo was hin muss.
Muss die hier da rein?
Ne.
Die muss da rein, oder?
Ne?
Die da rein?
Ich rate jetzt einfach mal.
Ich weiß nicht mal, welche Schrauben wo rein müssen.
Hier?
Die da rein?
Hä?
Kann es sein, dass ich das gar nicht richtig drin habe?
Also es ist definitiv richtig rum drin.
Nimmst du dir Zeit, die Hardware zu dokumentieren?
Äh, dokumentieren müssen nur Leute, die Sachen falsch machen.
Wir machen ja immer alles first try richtig, dementsprechend.
Ach, Moment!
Hier kommt überhaupt keine Schraube rein.
Das sieht nur so aus.
Da kommen überhaupt keine Schrauben rein.
Hier kommen die Schrauben rein.
Das ist, glaube ich, sogar die falsche Schraube gewesen.
Alter, wo kommt der Shit denn jetzt rein, Mann?
Da?
Ja, hier.
Hm.
Mein Finger ist zu dick.
Mein Finger ist zu dick, Leute.
White people fat.
Alter, was ein Scheiß, Alter.
Was haben sich die Chinesen hier wieder ausgedacht, Mann?
Okay.
Nice, alles dran.
Und jetzt kommt hier noch eine Schraube rein.
Das ist halt die letzte, die wir haben.
Die andere ist hier nur am Gehäuse.
Das ist egal.
Oh, oh, oh, nicht reinfallen, please.
Ja.
Okay, ja, die haben wir richtig erwischt, die Schrauben.
Okay, wir haben es wieder zusammen.
Zack, zack.
Wunderbar.
Pfunst.
GG Eats.
Okay, jetzt machen wir es zu.
Und dann stecken wir es mal in die Steckdosenleistung.
Also, ich werde nichts daran betreiben.
Das sage ich euch gleich, ja.
Und wenn jetzt gleich die Sicherung rausfliegt.
Aber da gibt es nicht allzu viel, was man verkehrt machen kann, eigentlich.
Ja, okay.
Dann kommt jetzt noch hier neben dieses komische,
dieses Zeugs da drauf.
Hier.
Wie auch immer das gescheit funktionieren soll.
Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gut.
Ja.
Okay.
sehr sehr saske
Funktioniert einfach drauf klipsen ich habe glück und first first try
Ich würde sagen das nicht ganz richtig oder
Oder doch ah ja das sieht doch schon deutlich besser aus
Okay, ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken wie das wie das logo bei den anderen ist
Dass ich die dass ich die richtig drauf setzte
Das milfra logo ist dort wo usb ist okay alles klar
milfra logo da wo usb ist also so
so zu ist
Milfra time
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt leute
Lasst mir mal eure predictions im chat da
Ob das jetzt gleich peters motor verfügbar ist
Wenn ich das einstecke
Ja
Okay, ich schalte ich schalte euch schon mal um wobei ihr wollt ja bestimmt sehen ob jetzt alles abfackelt
Habe ich überhaupt platz
Okay, das ist der switch den brauche ich jetzt eh nicht mehr
switch
Okay, es leuchtet rot ihr seht das nicht es leuchtet rot
Strom ist an
Raspberry Pi ist aus okay
Da ist sie
Und sie schaltet
Ich überlege gerade wie ich euch das beweisen kann dass sie schaltet so jetzt jetzt testen wir erst mal ob der usb standardmäßig immer an ist
Ja usb ist immer an das finde ich schon mal pp gar
Ich weiß wie ich weiß was wir ausprobieren können
Ja habe ich nicht irgendwo was mit usb
Netzteil anschließen
Raspberry Pi anmachen
Bis sie verkehrt ist sie verkehrt
Raspberry Pi anschließen
falsches kabel
Okay
Ich überlege habe ich nix besseres um euch das zu zeigen
Habe ich nix besseres wo man auch sieht dass irgendwas angeht
Ich meine beim Raspberry Pi sieht man es letztendlich auch weil er leuchtet aber
eine Lampe
Keine Lampe die man anschließen
doch
Brauche ich nur ein 5 Volt Netzteil mal gucken ob die noch funktioniert
Ich brauche einen 5 Volt Netzteil
Mit so einem mit so einem holstecker was ist das hier was habe ich hier für ein Netzteil was ist das
24 Volt oh ne das grillt meine Lampe 5 Volt Netzteil lasst mich mal kurz in meine Netzteilbox gucken
Ich habe keinen bock zu suchen wir machen das jetzt mit dem Raspberry Pi und gut ist kommt mal hier
Das geht schon ja
Warte mal seht ihr das
Ihr müsst ihr müsst ihr das eigentlich ihr müsst ihr das eigentlich jetzt von unten sehen
Versucht das mal irgendwie so hinzustellen dass man was man was erkennen kann
Ach komm ich drücke jetzt einfach auf Knopf und dann zeige ich euch dass es leuchtet mein scheiß drauf an
Seht ihr es leuchtet habt ihr es gesehen
Und jetzt mache ich mache ich aus
Jetzt ist aus
Funktioniert also man kann das remote schalten aber die sind tatsächlich eines der
sagen wir mal so feature ärmeren
Smartplugs weil
Du kannst das usb nicht getrennt schalten das ding misst den strom nicht
Und also die leistung nicht du kannst auch damit sprengen kein verbrauch
Dir da irgendwie auf lange fern langfristig draus ziehen und du kannst du kannst eigentlich nur den main anschluss ein und ausschalten
Ich meine okay für 9 euro vier stück da kann man sich nicht beschweren
Ich meine aber den normalen den standardpreis sind sie auf jeden fall nicht wert von dem von dem feature set her
Das hat im prinzip keine keine nennenswerten features. Oh jetzt blinkt sie
Warum warum blinkt die jetzt so komisch
Was ist da los
Jetzt blinkt sie ganz ganz merkwürdig und wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt anmache
Moment die blinkt wenn sie aus ist wenn mich das china dinge veräppeln
Die blinkt durchgehend wenn sie aus ist wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht alter
Na gut das kann man in das motor wahrscheinlich einschalten jetzt kann man wahrscheinlich das motor
Umstellen wie leds funktionieren das war jetzt aber nicht ich mache das ding jetzt
Ich mache das ding jetzt raus
Und das bleibt dann auch raus
Weil ich trau ich trau dem ding nicht so ganz ehrlich gesagt es hat zwar vor es mein
offensichtlich funktioniert ist
Und macht es was es soll
Aber
Weiß nicht
Irgendwie irgendwie traue ich diesem ding nicht
Wollte nicht das haus abfackeln mit mit milfra billig china chinesen steckdose
Naja wenn ein haus brennt kannst du amazon verklagen ja genau da da verlasse ich mich natürlich drauf das ist eine sehr gute idee
Das beste ist natürlich man
Lässt das haus erst gar nicht abbrennen weil man nicht in den billig kack verwendet
Was sonst für steckdosen benutzt alle möglichen sachen
auch auch
Amazon china sachen die ich aber alle ota geflasht habe wenn überhaupt
Also ich habe ganz viele von gosund gekauft
Weil die haben zwei usb anschlüsse die man schalten kann also immer zusammen aber
Aber usb die man usb remote ein ausschalten kann
Steckdose remote ein ausschalten kann und du siehst auch was aktuell das ganze so verbraucht was da dran hängt so plus minus über daumen gepeilt
Die sind feature technisch deutlich besser als diese milfra dinger
Was machst du denn so an die usb ports zum beispiel in meinem klo den esp32 betreiben also ich habe im klo so eine steckdose
Und in den usb
Anschlüsse an den usb anschlüsse ist einmal ein relativ langes lightning kabel dran
Um ein tablet zu laden ab und zu weil ich habe quasi die ganze zeit nur ein kabel zu laden
Und es ist ein esp32 dran der bluetooth empfang macht für meine
Bluetooth low energy
Xiaomi
Thermometer und luftfeuchtigkeit sensoren
Habe ich glaube ich fünf stück
Übersetzt
Und dann habe ich auch noch ein usb anschluss
Habe ich glaube ich fünf stück
Übers ganze haus verteilt auch auch natürlich geflasht mit custom firma
Durchfall tablet ja sogar dafür ist es praktisch auch wenn es mal ein bisschen länger gedauert hat auf dem klo war das tablet schon praktisch
Max bett geteilt ja gleiches bett geteilt und das beste ist wisst ihr was morgen muss ich nicht arbeiten
Weil montag ist ich muss euch mal was sagen
Ein
mal aus hier
Das war ja so ein halber il stream
Das ist deutlich anstrengender als einfach nur am computer sitzen und was basteln und und ein bisschen schwätzen
Da muss man nämlich dauerhaft schwätzen
Und und überlegen und was machen ich weiß gar nicht wie man das wie man das durchhält
Acht stunden am tag es gibt leute die machen sowas acht stunden am tag
Okay aber die die basteln die basteln die flashen auch ihre steckdosen nicht acht stunden am tag
Die die reakten eher auf videos
Aufpassen dass man sich nicht liegt ja das außerdem
Leute habe ich heute irgendwas geliegt irgendwie h ansatz oder
Irgendwelche dinger weil ich habe weil ich habe ja ziemlich
Ziemlich unterm
Ziemlich unter
Unter der kamera gehauen danke für die subs leute ich habe heute nicht wirklich darauf achten können
Vielleicht habe ich noch welche vergessen keksdose vor zehn minuten dankeschön habe ich nicht gesehen
Ich hoffe es hat euch heute auch gefallen
chat
Haben wir in letzter zeit lange nicht mehr gemacht bastel stream
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich hätte am anfang nicht gedacht dass wir das hinbekommen
Also das war schon
Bisschen schwieriger dadurch dass die anschlüsse so klein waren und wir hatten extrem glück
dass der button gepresst auf gpio 0 geht
Wenn der button nicht auf gpio 0 gewesen wäre hätte ich das noch selbst irgendwie dran halten müssen das wäre was geworden
Da hat da haben die die chinesen war ordentlich das gebaut ich meine
Ist bestimmt auch für die praktisch wenn sie einfach nur den knopf drücken müssen für neue firmware flashen
Was ich übrigens interessant fand dass bei diesem esp nahezu alles disabled war
Außer
neue firmware flashen
Firmware löschen ging nicht sachen auslesen ging nicht richtig
Aber firmware flashen das ging high security ja die wollen nicht dass man ihre firmware dumpt
Was ist flashen ja das was wir im stream heute gemacht haben die firmware austauschen auf dem auf der steckdose
Also sprich das was der hersteller ausliefert überschreiben mit eigener
Also eigener in anführungszeichen mit anderen sachen
Es läuft ja jetzt läuft da nicht mehr die die hersteller firmware drauf sondern eine eigene
Und die ist richtig nice weil mit der kann man ich habe schon zugemacht
Ja mit der kann man dann per browser drauf und einen ausschalten und auch viel besser in die heimautomatisierung integrieren
Erinnert mich dran wenn wir in einem der nächsten streams dann die anderen dinger die ich noch bestellt habe ausprobieren
Dann müssen wir also erinnert mich dran dass wir auch die steckdose in home assistant einbinden mit das motor die geflasht
Ich denke es hätte funktioniert nachdem du den gpio
gedrückt hattest
Ich habe den knopf an der seite gedrückt und dann hat es funktioniert und wenn er wenn es allerdings nicht mit gpio 0 verbunden wäre
hätten wir gelitten
Ansonsten verstehe ich den satz jetzt gar nicht
Die originale firmware hat bestimmt gruselige sachen drin
Ja erst mal alles im wlan scannen und nach china schicken vielleicht darf man es deswegen nicht nicht dampen
Ach du meinst es hätte auch funktioniert jetzt habe ich das verstanden du meinst es hätte auch
Funktioniert wenn das mit dem schalter nicht geklappt hätte wenn ich dann ein pinnt wenn ich dann irgendwas dran gehalten hätte
Ja naja ich habe es am anfang ja probiert da ging es nicht das könnte aber auch sein dass er ex und tx locker war
ne
Ne ne stand es stand explizit da
Read firmware not is not supported by this esp oder sowas
Das einzige was ging ist mac adresse auslesen speichergröße auslesen und neue firmware flashen
Du konntest weder die firmware löschen direkt was witzig ist weil überschreiben darfst du sie
Konntest du durftest weder die firmware komplett löschen
Ohne sie zu überschreiben noch durftest du
Firmware dampen im nächstes film die hersteller firmware dampen er hat ja nicht funktioniert
Den esp keine ahnung wie man das aus dem speicher auslesen kann
Andere bootloader das ist ein sp 82 66 ich weiß gar nicht ob der sowas
Den man ändern kann besitzt der sp 32 hat sowas da kann man
Dinger machen mit dem bootloader hauptsächlich allerdings
Du meinst die geräte die wir schon gepflascht haben
Ja kommt darauf an
Manche sachen gingen auch gar nicht auf was auch von den dingern die wir hier im stream probiert haben
vieles war die sehr sehr schnell
probiert haben vieles war deutlich einfacher weil die sich noch am ota flashen lassen aber
Doch doch der esp konnte doch die meck adresse dampen im gleichen step und hat dann gesagt dass firmware auslese nicht supportet ist
Der hat erst die meck adresse gedampft von dem von dem esp und dann hat er gesagt read firmware ist not supported
Also ich glaube nicht dass das irgendwie anders jetzt funktioniert hätte
Leute ich habe einen schwarzen fleck am finger
Meint ihr meinte ich habe mich da verbrannt vorhin echt irgendwie oberflächlich an dem an dem lötkolben
Ich habe so einen schwarzen finger ich hatte schwarzen schwarzen fleck am finger
Im kleinen ne ok da geht weg der geht weg vielleicht habe ich nur ein bisschen die haut ein bisschen verbrannt
Ich habe das gemerkt vorhin ich habe mich ein bisschen verbrannt
Aber ich bin ich bin nicht komplett dran gekommen ich bin nur in die nähe gekommen da habe ich schon gemerkt fakt ist es aber
heiß
Das war einfach nur dreck von vom basteln ich habe es könnte ging jetzt ab
Es hat auch nicht wirklich groß groß gebrannt normalerweise wenn man sich verbrennt das tut noch fünf minuten lang weh
Die herstellerfirma kann man ota updaten korrekt
allerdings ota updaten meinen die halt
Rund über die app updaten oder runterladen vom china chinesen server und mit ota
Flächen das motor mein ich
Übers über
Den lokalen wlan access point beziehungsweise ex lokalen
Wähler next point of raspberry pi das geht hier ging ja eine weile
Da hat der raspberry pi einen access point aufgemacht mit einer wlan ssid die quasi
dem hersteller der hersteller wlan
Ssid entsprochen hat die ist v trust
Und dann hat der esp gemeint oder connecten wir uns jetzt hin und holen uns neue firma sachen ab aber das ist nicht mehr
Möglich wenn die firma zu neues auf den kisten da sind die da nicht mal anfällig für nicht nicht wirklich so easy
Wahrscheinlich sind dinge auch signiert oder encrypted und die verbindung halten über nur über tls glaube nicht dass es so einfach funktioniert
Die alte von der handwerks ach du meinst dieses bild wo die den lötkolben
unten angepasst haben ja
Das bild war auch geil ja du meinst du meinst das hier gell damit das erste das erste bild genommen
Du meinst das hier oder
War das nicht war das nicht ein fake das bild hat sich nicht im nachhinein rausgestellt das war ein fake oder absichtlich verkehrt
Da hat sich doch da war da hat sich doch irgendwas raus rausgestellt dass das nicht nichts nicht so ist wie man dachte bei dem bild
Macht eigentlich eine lokale cloud sind eine lokale cloud widerspricht eigentlich dem wort cloud irgendwo schon
Man darf sich da nicht verwirren lassen dass so produkte wie next cloud
Das wort cloud im namen haben next cloud hat mit cloud eigentlich in der regel gar nichts zu tun
Cloud impliziert eigentlich dass es nicht deine infrastruktur ist
Ergibt so auch den spruch cloud sind einfach nur jemand anderem seine computer
Also
Lokale cloud ergibt eigentlich keinen sinn vom vom wort her
Ja, ich weiß es gibt
Leute die verkaufen software wo du in deinem rechenzentrum quasi
Eine umgebung bauen kannst die ein bisschen solchen
clouds
betreibern entspricht
halt für dich intern
Gibt ja mittlerweile auch schon sachen die
Lassen quasi kubernetes
Managed in anführungsstrichen auf einem esx cluster laufen ich habe vergessen wie das heißt vielleicht weiß es einer von euch
Wie heißt diese vm wer kubernetes geschichte die oben auf esx aufbauten dann automatisch auch notes professioniert und sowas das ist ein bisschen
so ähnlich wie
Wie man das kennt von einem managed kubernetes aber es ist immer noch in deinem rechenzentrum
Private cloud ist aber in der regel damit gemeint es ist bei einem cloud anbieter
Allerdings nicht öffentlich zugänglich das sind ja schon zwei komplett unterschiedliche schuhe
Weil ansonsten könnte ich mir auch ein kubernetes cluster daheim hinstellen mit drei raspberry pis und sage ich habe ich habe ich habe eine cloud
daheim ist ja auch blödsinn
Anzu ja das meine ich tanzu geld korrekt das meine ich ja
beim wer
anzu man könnte aber next cloud in der cloud betreiben ja kannst du machen
Wobei ich dann halt bedenken hätte über meine ganzen dokumente die ich da rein rein haue
Also macht durchaus sinn eine next cloud nur lokal zu betreiben aber dadurch wird es nicht nicht nicht cloud ich ja
Also für mich ist alles was im eigenen rechenzentrum
an einem standort läuft
Keine cloud man kann sich vielleicht drüber streiten ob man es nicht so nennen könnte wenn man mehrere standorte hätte in deutschland verteilt
Und die möglichkeit da beispielsweise anwendungen zu deployen die sich dann automatisch verteilen und beim ausfall
rüber gespiegelt vielleicht vielleicht könnte man das sagen aber sicherlich nicht bei es läuft am
firmenstandort in im rechenzentrum im keller das geht für mich auf jeden fall nicht als cloud durch egal wie viel cloud im namen der
Produkte drin ist und der vorteil bei cloud ist ja auch also neber neber dem
Dass du dich nicht drum kümmern musst
Nee das wollte ich das wollte ich gar nicht sagen
Genau ist ja auch gerade dass du dich nicht drum kümmern musst
Was du bei einem setup über eigene rechenzentren
Was über eigene rechenzentren streckt ja wieder machen musst also eines ist ja eines der hauptgedanken dahinter
Das betreibt jemand anderes für mich der beispielsweise auch besser weiß wie man
Managed kubernetes betreibt und ich kann es dann nur benutzen wenn ich das selbst mache
Ja da kann man sich vielleicht drüber streiten bei mehreren standorten so nach dem modell nennt man es doch cloud oder doch nicht
Aber man hat viele vorteile davon einfach nicht weil einer der größten vorteile ist dass man sich nicht selbst um den ganzen schritt kümmern muss
Wenn ich dazu wenn ich das in meinen eigenen standorten laufen habe dann kann man selbst selbst wenn man es cloud nennen darf oder nennen
Kann da muss ich mich immer noch um hardware kümmern os updates um alles unten drunter patchen im rechenzentrum
Netzwerkinfrastruktur sahen infrastruktur das ist doch für den arsch
da muss ich
Dann habe ich ja den größten vorteil von cloud nicht
Ans trinken erinnern mache ich jetzt gleich geht es ins bett
Danke fürs zugucken für die subs wir sehen uns ich denke morgen schon bis dann macht's gut